[Music]
[Applause]
oh
thank you thank you for being here on
this blessed after dark friday afternoon
today's episode is sponsored by kraken
and noon
and it's just a such a privilege and a
joy to be blessed on these fridays by
the one and only ela cline we love her
don't we folks
we love her it's such a treat it's such
a treasure having her here
that's what makes after dark great it's
the ela cliners and you look
you look fly as hell today what up big
pimps really thank you you don't think
you look good
no i went for like comfort today
why it looks awesome i love the the
green and the i mean first of all the
sweater is awesome but the green pops
and it makes you look really cute with
your eyes and your hair and you're
you're fleeking out
like you've been taking care of yourself
it shows yeah
i am trying let me see your nails i
didn't actually get a close look at them
oh you we got to get nail shots
do we have a nail shot cam for ela's
nails
where's that phone where we can get the
close shot yeah we got to do that we got
to get the nail shot all right yeah
how you been yellow i mean it's been a
week the people haven't seen you i'm
starting to really grow
my stomach
yes so you're wearing the overalls
the spacious yeah baby house
it's uh yeah it's it's cool otherwise
just um
a little uncomfortable sometimes but
it's still not too bad
uncomfortable like how just because you
feel so big loaded and yeah
[Music]
how so you're we're you're doing in uh
the beginning of february
and now we're in october already so
that's
how much time left october
december
that's it
[ __ ] three months because
i got two due dates from two different
doctors one said the end of january
right it was like the beginning of
february yeah so um let me do that again
october november december january okay
so we have four months right right right
thank god i need a little more time
before
baby world hits us
like a freaking freight train
yeah do you want to do any baby updates
because we got some [ __ ] we got some
kind of good news
i guess uh oh yes i did i got the news
about no drugs no drugs no drama
come on the blood results
um i've got the blood work back that i
was waiting for and it's all looking
normal so i think it's like most likely
it's there's nothing else going on which
is what
was pretty scary yeah we were worried
about the stomach having the first
doctor said there was calcium on the
stomach which is like a bad sign of
something
going on
but the second doctor the specialist
said he didn't see that just but the
stomach was small did we talk about this
already i don't think so i think we did
but then i was still waiting on the
blood results the blood test came out
good
i went the doctor asked me to go test
for a rare ashkenazi jew disease
and i went to do the blood test and the
lady pulling the blood was like i have
never seen this test before in my life
she had to get her supervisor to help
her find it in the computer that's so
weird she's like what is this
i was like bro i got rare diseases you
never heard of girl
that's what that pure blood is all about
come let's get a nail shot
hit us yeah thank you zach get it close
up there now thank you oh the music yeah
i was like you're calling me back no i
was thinking that the music no we got
a piece of my baby
he has shaky ass hands
what
[Music]
we got snoopy we got um
powerpuff what's that girl
um that's the bear from hello kitty oh
sick
yeah that's it kind of creepy really i
like it it's kind of soothing
okay thank you
thank you thank you thank you
nail game is on fire
[Applause]
before we get into it we have a great
episode of yep
oh gabe
today what you do you're in the library
i make a library
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] shh
what [ __ ]
what set what section are you in in the
library what what do you got behind you
there
i'm in the travel section trying to read
about traveling instead of studying
about
going places and stuff oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
baby friday what's up baby
baby
what what's today
it's the weekend friday [ __ ] yeah
sorry you got to be quiet i've been
alive no i understand i understand
i appreciate you making the time [ __ ]
baby
friday baby
is there people studying there can you
go show me around a little bit i'm gonna
see if there's people studying
oh there's one right there oh [ __ ] right
up in that [ __ ] huh
interesting people shameless love that
wow
yo is there school tomorrow
no school tomorrow is it worth their
library tomorrow [ __ ] yeah bro is the
library open on the weekend
yeah it is
like short hours
do you go to the library a lot
well when i'm not busy i've got nothing
to do i guess i just look at travels and
stuff oh that's pretty cool that storms
that's pretty like
that's pretty like classy i think that
you spend time in the library that's
cool oh yeah hell yeah
well gabe it's such a treasure to hear
from you are you doing well is
everything okay
everything's good nice nice you still
hey guys
good man how are you guys doing
good are you still crushing it on cameo
yeah pretty much
how many cameos you get in a day
how did you get 25 30. damn
wow
dude
wow god damn i'm so happy for you
well if you guys want to have froze
no i see you hello
i got you
you see me okay
yeah i saw you okay yeah you're the man
bro love you
well if you guys wanna
maybe yeah [ __ ] yeah on cameo you all
know where to find him white claw gabe
the legend
[Applause]
um would you go ask that guy right there
what he's reading
really no i'm just kidding you'd have to
do it i'm just kidding you don't have to
do it
all right gabe take care you have a
great weekend okay kick back a few of
white clothes for me
all right have a great weekend all right
youtube
friday baby [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] [ __ ] sheesh [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yeah
love that man
i love he's dropping f-bombs right i
didn't expect him to be so close to
people it kind of surprised me i thought
he'd be like tucked away in the corner
but no gabe was a real one what a legend
yeah absolutely
was that a setup or was he just
incidentally in the library
it's whatever you wanted to believe how
would we know
well usually we coordinate with him a
little bit but
he seems so earnest uh
in the library right yeah yeah okay
by the way yep the baby size now is the
size of a bell pepper
[Music]
bell pepper
pretty big
pretty small still though
it's small but that's pretty big too
because you you also have like
everything else around it like the water
but just think when you're getting kicks
it's a little creature this big one
it's kicking a lot
low foot this size
little bruce oh i just [ __ ] told the
man
you believe this idiot i do believe it
well whatever who cares yeah we're gonna
name him bruce after batman
not after batman either
um
some people guessed ethan is really
trying to just like
i i derailed this show with every minute
i didn't mean to say it
well it doesn't matter does it
i mean
you also kind of like ruined the gender
reveal but we were all trying to ignore
it that's not true yes you did look at
olivia i was aware of what i said
what did i say
you said we all thought it was a girl
no no no no
i wasn't confirming i said you are all
only took it that way because you all
knew the gender no because we're all
normal human beings you didn't see the
chat everyone was like that was like oh
okay
everyone voted still even after i said
because we were all trying to still save
the
at the time that it was a girl how else
would you how would you phrase that you
don't say that well i feel like you just
can't because it was like
shoot me
chad is saying you totally did how else
am i supposed to say that i was just
referencing that we thought it was a
girl
well you are arguing with all of us here
and 26 thousand viewers right now yeah
so i think somebody's wrong
all right so you'll kill me now
you want that baby to have a daddy or
not just saying
just saying just saying
yeah well bruce is the name because it
we like the one i don't know if it's the
name anymore now really yeah also
because you said it's after batman i was
just totally you were not
was there any insinuation of kidding
anyone obviously i'm kidding i'm not
naming the baby i do like batman but not
that i said that because i didn't say it
like you're kidding because i have the
context i know that you're kidding but
the audience is not gonna understand i'm
saying now listen to me
we even had a conversation saying like
it's not after batman
i'm telling you now for us to
oh my god
how about uh
batman
you should you should just surprise him
ela i feel like angry eel is angry at me
i don't know what i did i am and i'm
also pregnant so don't
push it
because i get more angry at little
things right now
than i should
you left me in a black hole of raging
confusion
listen i'll to prove it to you guys it's
not after batman yeah
my mom my grandfather passed away
recently his name was um
well we called him jerry but his name
was uh
albert yeah
i never called him by his name that's
why i was like trying to recall he was
always jerry
and so
we wanted to give his middle name albert
but we're like it's too close to alfred
and it'll seem like a batman meme
so there you go proof
it's not a batman meme like bruce alfred
klein
i don't know i can't win today
i'm just trying to do a show here and
everyone hates me i i like the batman
names it's not a bad bad name zach thank
you
what do you think about scarecrow klein
how about joker climb exactly yeah mud
face
all right you want to move on yes god
i'm gonna get killed when we get home
just trying to enjoy friday baby and
everything just turned around on me
i'm just going to order pizza and sit in
solitude
great
i left that yogurt store and didn't get
the yogurt that i wanted i know
traumatic
all right well a quick shout out to ela
who hates my guts
uh new drop just came out on thursday
abey's actually modeling this uh hoodie
for us today let's go ahead show it off
baby
we got the rhinestones baby it's fresh
it's hot it's embroidered show it off
show it off show it off show it off show
it
out
you like it
that's hot of course i like it it's
blinged out it's like pretty fresh it's
a it's i mean it's different you know
here it is you got in brown black
pink you got the matching
uh
bottoms
you got the i flunked out of college and
all i have was this sweatshirt ian was
wearing that one today do you mind
standing up looked real good on you
stand up here
yeah that looks real nice
just so you know it's teddy fresh it
says teddy fresh teddy fresh teddy fresh
tf with three bears so just in case
super comfortable anyone asks what brand
you're wearing oh it is okay that's good
thank you
yeah but did you guys see how hot he
looked
thank you that does sound right it's
really sweet we have ac in here dan
uh the jacket everyone wanted his bath
we got striped sweaters we got this
classic revenge of the ted sweater i
don't know how many people actually
remember it yeah this is a kick oh
classic yeah
uh women's giddy up cardigan this one's
real nice it's really ordered that one
you did yeah
that first of all that's very sweet of
you but we can hook you up oh well did
you get a coupon code or something from
lina honey
he did i got yeah wait honey worked yeah
honey's not supposed to work on our
website
no but we you have an employee this
cause
yeah you have an employee discount but
you also can get no but
you freaked me out because honey
sometimes messes our website up
oh is it because my email is attached to
no ha this is a testament to honey no
honey they're so good
that
when one if we give someone a coupon
code for like a one-time use they go
crazy and recommend it to everyone and
like [ __ ] their whole whole
yeah yeah so you scared me when you said
honey worked
but i think it was just a coupon code
anyway shirt sucks go ahead go over the
website check it out see if there's
anything you like peace and no peace and
love
thank you
damn
nothing
nothing
nothing oh we have a photo of everything
here i'll just show this real fast so
you can see a nice up close
tapers.com teddyfresh.com
teddyfresh.com made ela made each piece
she sweat and bled and cried over each
one of these pieces
that's it okay thank you thank you
all right oh speaking of ela being a a
legend
the foot soldiers went immediately to
work yeah the ethan's uh wife meme with
his wife
i saw lots of funny comments about it
has a good show
[Music]
yeah well they fixed it it says american
artist now yeah
that's so cool that's the that's the
power of uh
grassroots baby foot soldiers unite i
wonder who actually chose the american
artist like
i think it must have been someone at
google because there's no wikipedia page
or anything that it's pulling it from so
somebody there
that's sweet though american artist that
sounds nice youtuber sounds lame bro
like compared to that i wonder what it
says also american
pretty cool oh yeah that's true if you
think about that aren't you you're
actually not
well you are i'm american you are i mean
you're a citizen yeah that's very
american
ethan what does it say for me new
american
where where is it does it say anything
for me like i think it says father of
batman
oh wow
do you study h3h3 productions or ethan
ethan clive yeah well
i guess because it read just goes to
it assumes you want the channel and then
it says youtube youtube channel yeah i
guess it's the first thing you're just
going to name those and do whatever you
want on them say what
you can claim it and do whatever you
want type whatever you want are you
serious
look at the bottom of the square it says
claim this knowledge panel if you scroll
down a little bit
right
oh for some reason it doesn't say for
you but oh it says youtuber c lame
i don't want to be a youtuber lame bro
is ethan klein rich
let's find out
ethan klein is an american comedian love
that
that's pretty cool that is that is much
cooler than youtuber it says we have
there you see it claim this knowledge
panel on the right
oh i can write whatever i want are you
from oh
oh i'm not gonna i'm gonna get all this
but i'm gonna be like
can i write astrophysicists yeah
probably
anyway congratulations ela thank you and
thank you to
the foot soldiers yeah the foot soldiers
got they went to work for you now i have
a question for you this is going to be a
section we're going to be doing some
polling
uh we're going to need some input from
ela since you weren't here to see what
happened
but essentially
we were going back and forth
on
our uh title and thumbnail for
yesterday's
episode yeah okay let me show it
so here's what we landed on
terrible news
now there what okay so let me explain
the process of how we got yeah
explain well we played the um
silent library which everyone loved by
the way thank you for
for that i haven't watched it yet but i
cannot wait i mean everyone is saying
it's like the best off the rails it was
fun and the best i think looking back i
mean like
i mean all you guys were amazing
i mean first of all ian the fact that
ian ate that i saw that clip and i was
shocked dude
i mean you can't even possibly fathom
what went in that man's mouth yeah
atrocious it was
i can't believe
well it took like all night to get the
smell out of the building
well anyway and then and then a b with
the spicy nug that was impressive zach
just went to work on everything
willingly by the way
it was a rough night after
very impressive uh performance
but um
and then with the mayo
no mayo no no no no i beat cake i see
they wanted to do mayo
it was fun yeah
well anyway if you guys haven't watched
it was good
but you know we uploaded it and we did
like
uh we ate the grossest food or whatever
and this happens every every time
we upload a video where everyone's like
this is the best episode ever it's 10
edit it's like bottom worst views ever
right right on that's always been true
yeah
even before when we're making youtube
videos yeah
if there was something
we both thought was really good it would
like be the worst
yeah yeah on youtube it tells you your
last 10 videos how your latest one is
performing in comparison to them and it
was 10 it was number 10 out of 10 the
episode that we buy a lot by a lot so
usually what happens when it's 10 out of
10 we go well obviously it's the
thumbnail and title because the content
is good yeah
so we ended up with so what we started
with was a b had a picture of him in the
hospital
and we said well that makes sense
because a b got really sick
but then we're like well if it's my face
it'll get more views
so then all of a sudden it ended up with
me in the hospital which had which is no
connection
at all to anything that happened
do we have the whole progression in this
album yeah i have a whole progression of
the thumbnail so it's terrible news me
in the hospital and it has absolutely no
bearing at all on the video
so i'm kind of conflicted this was the
first one
okay and that didn't do well horrible
i mean that's like the honest one
i think still the best one might be just
silent library because i have a feeling
there's gonna be people that want to
watch it i see lots of people uh
becoming members thank you so much that
is very uh meaningful and helpful we
love our members thank you thank you
with peace and love you guys are the
greatest
and also members are going to get
treated to an extra early episode sorry
alfred
this saturday the leftovers is going up
and it's a great episode absolutely
sunday for the general public
um i think anyway we anyway so here's
this one
so then they're
that's my favorite this is out of order
so then hang on
yeah so i'll just go down so here here's
me in the hospital
here's me laughing this is a david
dobrik thumbnail it's my favorite by far
it's so [ __ ] fun
we like this one but like i was like
people are not gonna make it doesn't
make any sense yeah it's like lots of
inside jokes yeah
it's funny but
i'm working for cl and then here's a b
he died a b
a yad 1992-2021
are you comfortable with us clickbaiting
your desk
i don't mind but i was like it was a
little creepy when cam was editing it
this is a little weird
oh my god rest in peace bud
here's me this one's the worst
this is the worst that's pretty funny
too
the one of you laughing
look at this idiot i almost killed a b
yeah i ran over a b with a uh excavator
that's totally what david would do for
good
and ethan's defense he felt bad we kept
especially me and love and i feel like
me love are the most like youtube
inclined out of the crew at least like
we watch the most youtube we find that
clickbait hilarious and we're always
pushing for it sort of like an
off-the-rails meme
for sure it is an off-the-rails meme
which i enjoy but this one usually
there's like somewhere where you could
like be like okay this is where they got
it this one has nobody
click baiting my [ __ ] that i got
seriously injured with no relation to
anything like if somebody wanted to find
this video this episode and the silent
library they couldn't find it right
they couldn't find it
there was one a couple weeks ago where
we made a fake mug shot of you and the
title was ethan got arrested which also
just
what was that was that one related to
something we did tick tock challenge of
the fake arrest yeah
okay at least there was some okay you're
right there was a correlation yeah
[Laughter]
just [ __ ] straight up nothing there's
nothing related to it so i don't know i
wanted to get people's vote on this if
we should
to tell you the truth that it did help
the views i i hate to say
they immediately shut up quite a bit
like i remember people were not much
though does it make you think that
people are not worried enough for you
because
what like oh no one cared nobody gave
[ __ ]
well we've been doing it for a while so
i mean this is definitely the most
extreme but yeah but i mean the um
i'm looking at the
the views here yeah i mean it it shot up
quite a bit
so you got to tune in off the rails to
find out what happened
somebody in the chat said i was looking
for the silent library episode last
night and thought you deleted it yeah
exactly
that's kind of self-defeating i wonder
if we should just call it silent library
you know
sound library in the thumbnail stays the
same of you in the hospital the silent
library
it's such a pain in the ass this whole
youtube [ __ ] what do people what's the
consensus there
um in the chat yeah uh
i mean a lot of people are saying it's
funny but then that i call that fraud
that's fraud it isn't advertisement it
definitely is false it's big time false
evidence
yeah let's do it so what's the poll well
the poll is basically and i think it's
gonna be obvious but um
uh ethan fake death meme or
just call it silent library i mean but
the thing is what would the thumbnail
look like
if you make an actual silent library
thumbnail it's something we got to work
on i guess i don't know so the poll is
just what should we do
ethan keep it fake death
i was thinking we could change it in
like three days after you know the
initial push so people could find it so
ethan fake death meme or change it to
silent library is that the poll yeah
okay here we go
i mean asking the community the thing is
like the obvious answer is change it but
you don't what you don't understand is
that
it was like our worst performing episode
ever made
ooh
early results are pretty close really
it's kind of neck and neck silent
library's winning by just uh by five
percent
[Music]
we can do the big reveal on the show
here
what do you think
a lot of people are also writing the you
pointing at a b one
but it doesn't make any sense
no no one doesn't make a that one at
least has a correlation to it no it does
it does but like as a thumbnail i feel
like for anyone yeah anyone outside
yeah this looks insane like what the
[ __ ] is this
like what could you even title it
i sent one of my employees to the
hospital
oh my god awful we're gonna need more
than five percent may he simp in heaven
nobody's picking i killed him i killed
myself
i killed my greatest sim
i killed my biggest fan he died for me
abe died lol i killed my biggest fan
i've gone wrong sexual i killed my
greatest mike i ki i accidentally killed
him that that's what david will call is
like he i accidentally killed him or
something parentheses emotional yeah fan
made up gone wrong
[Laughter]
okay here's a legit um
super chat question go ahead didn't
ethan criticize youtubers for doing
clickbait titles and now he's doing the
same hmm
it's a self-aware meme like you've
always done in your career all your h3
videos that's what you're doing you're
making fun of the trending yeah
uh i mean that's a generous
interpretation this this one is just uh
this isn't my first vlog shameless this
one is bad
that's why i felt bad about it it's
[ __ ] hilarious it is funny though i
mean it's funny but it's also just i
mean look i make fun of people that
clickbait like their kids dying i mean
that that's [ __ ] up i'm i'm
clickbaiting myself dying
that's [ __ ] up
[Music]
but this is the tradition of off the
rails we always do these uh i guess the
thing is that times change i think
that's what people
don't understand and youtube changes so
much it's like i don't know
like
back then i would have been like in no
way
i was also very like 100 against
clickbait but in this time now it just
seems funny like it's not that serious
yeah well
it's not it's not something we like if
we were like if we clickbaited like
something happened to the baby right
then obviously that would be pretty dark
yeah yeah
guess what
yeah man
benefits everybody yeah i don't see the
problem here hurts
nobody so what's the final verdict there
dude it's like unbelievably close we're
over 10 000 votes now and it's ethan
fake death meme at 48
change it to silent library 52 so
there's a difference of 4
wow
less than five percent dude four percent
in the astronomical it is uh is cam
gonna work on one during yeah let's see
what cam let's see what cam can cook up
and then we can
we can decide on that right
but in the meantime
zach
a foot sol dude the footstool is so
powerful lately someone i don't know if
you saw this either someone bought the
billboard
for zach
i i
skipped her but i was waiting to watch
it on the episode shout out to larry
lynch legend
[Music]
zack
[Music]
let me get it zoom oh that's it he shows
it he shows it more clearly in just a
second we just wait there
let's take a look oh dude zach the true
mayor
and the cameo this guy this guy was so
nice i saw this on the sub and i'm i was
blown away like it it was so [ __ ]
nice
wow love larry so shout out to larry big
shout out to hillary thanks big big
shout out to
larry the legend he explains early on in
the video that he uh
it was unclear to me if he worked for an
ad agency or actually directly for the
billboard company but he had some
connection that he was able to pull this
off
is that it like how much how many
rotations did you get
uh
it didn't it's still going
yeah
i imagine it was up for a while yeah
cannabis delivery
all these people are getting free plugs
by the way burger king laughing right
now huh is that the mayo king baby
i mean i'm blown away there you go you
finally got what you deserved there on
that one
also a huge
congratulations to ab we all obviously
had a very difficult conversation where
a b confronted us
because he felt he wasn't getting enough
fan art and he had kind of a meltdown
and so
he had a bit of a diva moment
so i don't know what this one is that's
me and lean on the top right this is one
of the original artists that we showed
last week and so they completed the
piece with me lena and hassan sam olivia
there you go do you feel better
yeah it wasn't so much
go ahead that there wasn't fan art it
was that i was left out
yeah so he was he basically was hurt
that people were leaving he
yeah all right he was very upset yeah
we had kind of an emergency
clout goblin
how do you like this one i mean it's
nice i think it's really cool i hate the
clout goblin title but it's very i love
the art though yeah the art looks good
here's one that uh this is cool i need
that club here's one that hopefully will
be up to you to your level of incredible
attention
um
they're all a b
so even shredders absolutely
and alfredo so is that one up to your
yes this is beautiful okay good
that's bone fork by the way yeah
probably the most showcased artist in
fan art sundays
bone
uh fan art for the number one synth that
one's just straight up
oh here you go ab beautiful this is
really cool yeah lena loved this one too
excellent thank you appreciate you guys
this was a really powerful one through a
b sitting at denny's at 1am wait i love
that
did you draw that i did not i didn't
know you were such a talent i did not
say incredible dude yeah it wasn't me
did you draw that at the denny's who put
this together i was i've just wanted to
include the funny ones but maybe was
this you
did you put this together zach put it
together
okay i put it together because i was
like there's too many serious ones here
did a quick oh there you go very kawaii
here's some good av fan art
i heard abe wanted some fan art here you
are pretending to rescue a family out of
a burning car
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh a b
you look kind of like ryan cavanaugh
here
um there's too many serious ones here
guys
well you weren't too specific you should
just put them together i thought we were
like
this is great
[Laughter]
jesus there's a lot of them
so here my
this was my favorite i was heartbroken
here a b wasn't getting fan art don't
worry buddy i got you and here you are
saying michael jackson did nothing wrong
and uh
well what do you think about this one
i knew that this one was the whole point
of this segment yeah exactly this is
what i wanted more of that this is what
you wanted less of this
more of this
yeah
do you still hold that opinion by the
way
don't be shy
just be honest
it's okay
you're not alone
let's have one week
one friday
but we can enjoy it oh like a big happy
family
i don't know what you're referring to
did michael jackson do i feel like
somehow we always lead back today so do
you still like david dobrik do you still
watch david dover no no no no no i will
never ask you such a question wait but
okay so no so your answer is no
seems like
and that's fine i mean everyone's
entitled their opinion some people think
oj is innocent you know i will say
victim blaming ain't cool
i learned that with my cancellation
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you think oj is guilty yes okay oh so
you think so you see how fast he
answered that [ __ ]
racist
okay let's move on thank you ap we do
love you and uh that was fun stuff brett
uh 36 minutes i think it's time for the
ad having too much fun let's let's blast
through these ads so we can get to more
fun or don't put that on the screen
cracking
hey guys are you interested in investing
in crypto currencies but aren't sure
where to get started check out the
kraken app
with cracking you can buy and sell over
50 of the most popular cryptos like
bitcoin dogecoin and ethereum on the go
24 7.
it's super easy to get started just
download the app create your account and
you'll be investing in minutes
one of the coolest things about buying
crypto through kraken
is that you don't need a lot of money to
try it out so even if bitcoin is trading
at forty thousand dollars you can buy as
little as ten dollars worth on kraken
just get your feet wet see if you like
the the
vibe of trading and buying and investing
in crypto that's nice
find out for yourself why kraken has
been one of the highest rated places by
crypto for the last 10 years visit
kraken.com after dark now to learn more
or search for kraken in the app store we
love kraken the owner is a friend of the
show he's a great guy so uh please
consider
using kraken for your crypto needs
thank you to kraken and finally a big
thank you to noom
today's sponsor is noom noom is a
digital health platform that helps
empower you to take control of your
health
newm focuses on building healthy
routines and habits because there's so
much more to being healthy than just
losing weight and dying diet
i believe i've heard that from you once
or twice
uh i've actually i have actually used
new
i i was pretty um
committed to the new program
it's it's really cool because it's so
interactive you learning about nutrition
you're learning about how much fitness
you need to be doing in a day which
foods are healthy it's really cool
because they when you put in the food to
count your calories it analyzes like um
if this is a food that's going to fill
you up and it's healthy they'll give it
like a green and if it's junk food or
somewhere in the middle to give it a
yellow or red i actually learned a lot
because there's some stuff that i
thought was like okay this is okay to
eat and it turned out to be red
like one example of a food that i
learned was really bad is like granola
like you're like
that seems good right yeah but there's
so much sugar in it and it's so dense
with calorie and sugar that it's a red
that's surprising yeah
so you actually end up learning a lot um
yeah a cup of of
granola
is like freaking 300 cal i mean it's a
lot
it's also into the psychology of losing
weight staying healthy
and uh you have uh you know helps keep
you track and and provide motivation
i love the food tracking feature this is
kind of what i just explained red yellow
and green foods based on how much it
fills you up and how many calories you
consume it's really educational about
what foods are going to set you back
versus the healthier option you start by
taking a quick assessment used to tailor
a custom plan for you if you're like me
and want to build healthy habits and
take control of your health you can get
a free noom evaluation and seven day
trial when you use my link at noom.com
after dark once again when you use my
link in the description you'll get a
free new evaluation and seven day trial
so go to noom.com
after dark thank you thank you
[Music]
nice
oh great there's already meme
the batman light is being cast on your
stomach
great
oh speaking of which uh another
reference to the last
video
uh we did this part ila where
um we waxed abey's armpit
oh
lena came in and did it
and somebody made a very apt
uh or actually no i think this was a
screen recording someone hacked in james
charles phone yeah
so james charles is actually a fan of
the pockets and here he was watching
that moment from it so oh right there
you have hair on your chest
[Laughter]
i mean an honor or what have you feel
honored or grossed out
i knew when when you bust out your
armpit hair there was going to be people
you know i wish he saw that they're
strapping before the mall because then
maybe he would have came up to me
right
oh my god this is the t
you're in this hall of fame now maybe
you're in his you're in his spank bank
now buddy sister spank bank
[Laughter]
you know um
let me see
oh god and i can't escape this whole
denny's meme this freaking
dumbass caller wait what the [ __ ] is
this me leaving denny's i didn't see
this
okay that wasn't part of the story
actually we have a relevant donation
mega flygon uh donated 23 and said i
remember ethan
we used to call him the booth burner
climb bbk for short dude would slam hell
eggs and assault the seat with caustic
farts i always wondered what old
bbk was up to looks like he made a
career of it
congratulations thank you megan
i told ela about the denny's call and i
was like you go ahead you you weigh in
help help me out here
well that's definitely not something
that would ever happen thank you i would
never go to denny's by myself
but i started seeing all these memes i
was like hmm something happened on the
show
people freaking lie on my name dude i
don't know i want to sell him out or
anything but there's a lot of
contradictory evidence hilo there is
none we've seen cctv footage
you know there's also a quick trust me
if if ethan ever gets out of the house
it's because i
beg him and then we're going to get her
somewhere well said
well said in my defense thank you
you've never snuck out for it oh that's
interesting what do you guys think of
this ah
but maybe
so i'm in the library and i'm
in pain and agony
it says silent library can we are going
to be looking for this segment what what
if it's in the hospital like what if
you're next to a b
wait it's just confusing
can you i don't know if the lines behind
me are working
oh i didn't realize there were lines
yeah
okay thank you dan
um you know this this is something we've
been meaning to do for a while now we've
owed it to this man
bogues for a while right
you can't see it but it already can see
it over your black shirt
yeah
this is the best wendy williams
fart remix award that we promise
promised bogues so long ago
so we finally made the award we're going
to send it to him come and read what
does it say at the bottom it says death
to all the competition
just to refresh folks won our wendy's
william fart remix competition here so
i'm calling out
right now musicians who are really good
at making digital music to
you know
i want that beat
i know there's like a dope ass beat
somewhere there between all those sounds
is that 35 000 plays that's awesome yeah
that is awesome should be way more
yeah crank it it's okay
here we go
[Music]
yo this is straight like
edm drop
i could definitely throw back some
[Music]
ecstasy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do we have his address we have his
information
sam is uh uh getting in touch with him
so congratulations
congratulations
we keep our promises here on the show we
should even if it's a year late
yeah totally we need to that's fine we
gotta find a good also um i think the
sound by sound bite to your list is
something we should do again soon yeah
there's been a lot of updates since then
yeah yeah yeah yeah i knew about that i
mean that was a lot of fun
last time
i saw someone asking are you going to do
steamies
well now what trip then right trisha
being out of the picture
i don't know
the steamies i i can't imagine doing it
by myself
right maybe a new political award show
with us on
now that sounds [ __ ]
boring
[Laughter]
all right let's get to the juice face
blanks
says that him and jason nash been
talking mad [ __ ] about me
all right blanks
watch his death noodles with the uh
i would love to have him on man i've
been seeing him out and about and that
guy is a [ __ ] great guy man
he is a great guy and we just crashed
you already know we just cracked the
funniest humor the whole time just yeah
i'm sure you're cracking the [ __ ] i've
never heard facebook the funniest humor
is that what
yes
he says you already know we
jason ash is like a professional
comedian i i believe he's funny the guy
can't talk that's what i'm saying like
i've never heard him say a funny thing
that's how i know he's lying because he
says we crack each other up i'm like
[ __ ] you didn't even say that he said
we cracked the funniest humor yeah what
blanks right what
[Laughter]
like uh
like a very that's like a very clinical
uh
uh description of joking around with
somebody i think he's [ __ ] stupid
i don't know because in the real world
like
you know sometimes we run into these
like weird little h3h3 situations where
people just
are just really just talking [ __ ] you
know what i mean oh yeah i'm talking
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
blank minded dumbass
i mean you're friends with keemstar how
how do you just walk around and pretend
like that's normal
like that that that i i always say about
faze blanks the worst thing i can say
about him is that he's friends with
keemstar and that's a lot that says a
lot about a person
yeah
it's an automate like you get
disqualified
from
a lot of things oh yeah
huh
you shouldn't be able to drive if you're
friends with keemstar
you should have your your all your
license revoked you can't operate heavy
machinery absolutely not that is a
danger to society
i don't even know about a salt gun
oh even a salt gun no no no no the bug
assault yeah you said a salt gun that
actually sounds like a weapon
a gun that shoots salt yes that's too
dangerous
i hate keemstar
talk it's just [ __ ]
you know twitter fingers um yeah but in
the real world bro people don't behave
like that they don't operate that way so
it's just it's funny to be in um like
real life situations or like an event or
a party or something social like that
and just
it just hits you it kind of hits
everyone like [ __ ] is so dumb just crack
wait what the [ __ ] what is this story
are you high bro
what are you talking about you started
you started talking about jason nash
right i'm saying that
me and jason ash crack like h3h3 humor
when we're with each other and like just
make like funny comments about the
that's how i know he's lying there's no
way he said anything funny about me yeah
the way that's
the way that's worded is kind of weird
i know he words everything kind of me
and cam were talking about this we kind
of have a theory that he was actually
saying that he was they were commenting
on internet culture making fun of it the
way that you guys do
and then
yeah they're not funny they're not funny
they're our enemies that's coming up
next but
i think he's saying we were making fun
of h3
i thought so at first too but just now i
don't know that kind of sounded like he
was like we make like h3h3 humor like
your style of humor together
no way then wait i got it i got it he
was i think he was dead i think he's
that dumb he doesn't know how to convi
he doesn't know how to express himself
he's a fan dude
well zach he was a big fan he's
mentioned it right well hold on hold on
because he says at the end that i'm not
funny
well that may have been trying to start
nailing this keystore may have reeled
him in a little bit let me play the
whole thing i'm not going to interesting
let's unravel this people are saying um
that hassan is a
phrase blanks
fan i needed to ask him because i i saw
him saying once like i never say [ __ ]
about faze blanks and i don't know what
the affinity he has towards him um i'm
not going to hold that against the song
yeah be friends with whoever he wants
fine it's not that serious
like i said my biggest problem with faze
is that he's friends with keemstar i
mean i genuinely i genuinely believe
that
i think brother banks
i think friar banks
throw him fryer
and say what we mean
i think he might be a fan i think he
might be a fan and i think all of this
is just is just her feelings message me
message me we can swatch the beef
i'm infinitely small but the thing is
i'm infinitely more successful than you
the thing is bro you can't
you can't overlook keemstar like that's
like being friends with jeffrey epstein
it's like you might be the coolest
[ __ ] in the world but like you
hang out with jeffrey epstein right like
i can't overlook that i hear you i hear
you more like satan but
yeah well i agree with that
so is that worse than jeffrey epstein or
not as bad as jeff just a different kind
of yeah epstein's more specific
different kind of evil than body made of
evil like star i agree with that mm-hmm
really
very charles man very accurate
satan
[Music]
satan with an affinity for young girls
well yeah i mean that that screams satan
right there
all right let's let's try to unravel
that's realistic
because the way it's fixed it's like you
gotta
you gotta yeah let's pause and try to
analyze let's decide
i'm gonna play the whole thing
and then let's try to unpack this
it kind of hits everyone like [ __ ] is so
dumb just crack wait what the [ __ ] what
is this story are you high bro
what are you talking about you started
you started talking about jason nash
right i'm saying
me and jason ash crack like h3h3 humor
when we're with each other and like just
make like funny comments about the
internet and just he's a [ __ ] really
funny guy and his he's got a good soul
that was my point i would love to have
him on the show
i'm so confused h3h3 is not funny i'm
not talking about bro are you [ __ ]
high right now
i'm talking about
no i'm talking about just i think he's
trying to cover his ass i love that they
both can't understand each other yeah
i'm more confused because that first on
second listen this is high level content
by the way i really need to start
listening to this
this is a spotify original show my
friend
coming at you with high level thoughts
and ideas this is the first uh three
minutes of the show as well oh my gosh
it just
started i think i think he was trying to
say h3 issues style humor yes but but i
think when keem's like what are you
talking about faze tried to cover his
ass
really he was admitting that he's a fan
and likes you yeah but so even keemstar
has said he's funny it's like can you
just give me that like you could say i'm
a douche and i'm an [ __ ] but he goes
no ethan's not even funny okay i'm
starting no he can't say that he said
that the puppet's funny
yeah when he's trying to be cool he said
the pup is funny he's trying to play
cool but he can't even i tapped his at
that puppet ass
he said that because
the whole snitching he can't take it
back he said it that's true even if he
didn't mean it he said it though we all
know okay so wait roll it
let's decipher that well so death noodle
we while you were gone we
were coming around to what you were
saying
i think you're right but hold on hold on
let's try this again because he he does
a 180 so let's listen closely now okay
this story are you high bro
what are you talking about you started
you started talking about jason nash
right i'm saying
me and jason ash crack like h3h3 humor
when we're with each other and like just
make like funny comments about the
internet and just he's a [ __ ] really
funny guy and his he's got a good soul
that was my point you could almost
interpret that he's saying i'm a funny
guy i have a good thing
him making zach are you high bro yeah
are you [ __ ] are you [ __ ] high bro
if you if you misconstrued it enough it
gets bad
this is like deep literature you have to
like what am i doing listening to the
daily
yeah the daily new york times this is
way more [ __ ] fast
okay so wait this is when this one you
really need to think okay
because so far the interpretation is
that
he he likes
my humor yeah right mm-hmm but now
but now cameron is upset let's see what
happens
i'm so confused h3h3 is not funny
i'm not talking about bro are you
[ __ ] high right now
i'm talking about
okay now here this is when he clarifies
this is important
because he's like i'm just trying to
make a point are you [ __ ] high and
not talk about age three necessarily and
then kim starts like you what you find
ethan funny are you [ __ ] high to say
that [ __ ]
no i'm talking about jason nash being
funny i'm saying we crack jokes about h3
yeah he says he's joking about yeah that
was him
that's not what he said to begin with
yeah but he clarified okay no you're
right the clarification is cut and dry
he's like we making fun of h3 but i
think i think that might have been a
slip yeah he wanted to say it so at
first when keem first interrupt and it's
like what are you saying he's like no
i'm talking about jason nash that part
was jason and then after because he like
realized that he was getting upset
because the fact that i'm in right now
i'm following him so he so he has the
end to message me saying your name in
the mom's basement studio is like saying
voldemort exactly so i don't know about
that they love to throw it out there but
they seem pretty awesome but but it has
to be in a negative negative right yeah
keem's a fan he had a meltdown when he
almost insinuated i was funny right he's
a fan everyone loves you and they just
can't admit it
and fate
to be honest i always felt like keemstar
hated me just because that one time it
all goes back to when i was like we
don't like him too
and he that's when he lost his mind
because he wants to be friends so
desperately it's like how the batman
story they always go back to like that
one scene when his parents died
this is the kingstown story it is
keemstar was
born that one time you left the comments
and that's the monster was born in that
yeah i'm in a sea of slander and lies
well that's when he first
did the legendary uh death to all
noodles uh sound bite i'm not going to
say whatever that's all noodles
death to all juice juice
juice all jews
death to all jews
yeah i'm anti-semitic
we know that
and that's why it's weird that people
associate with you hold on let me finish
this like
just like how dumb it is
this is the best content this is [ __ ]
that was awesome that was way better
than i expected
one minute 25 seconds of gold i listened
further but that's where it ended
banks hit me up bro dm me let's talk it
out did you just clarify it were you
saying i'm funny or
that you like making fun of me okay all
right if
he said boats basically so which one was
it
if you if you want to bury the hatchet
you can dm me but i'll just tell you bro
you're friends with the devil with an
affinity for young girls
aka jeffrey epstein no
[Music]
no keemstar talks to girls that are of
age
yeah i said young girls yeah yeah i know
i'm just clarifying i don't think we can
throw around the episode so easily
the devil we could throw around
definitely hold on keemstar's like
epstein if he didn't have money or power
no but epstein like actually did a lot
of horrific uh proven it's too specific
okay so how about um
there's real victims that you know okay
okay fair enough fair enough how about
um
keemsteen
sounds like you're making him jewish
[Laughter]
keemstein
keemstar is down it's a keemstar wait
what's in the devil oh this is [ __ ]
interesting jason nash subscribed to the
podcast recently
is that what that shows
i have to say i have very conflicted
feelings about jason after
everything that's happened
the thing is like obviously what
happened with seth was [ __ ] up
and that's something that
he needs to own and apologize for
but all the trisha details i like the
dog thing we showed i mean that was just
a flat out fabrication so everything
trisha said about him i just i don't
know what to believe anymore
you know
you're not gonna get any response from
me so let's move on
can we have jason as a let me ask you
this could jason ever be like a guest on
the podcast
could we have a conversation
the pandora's box is open yeah it's
gonna be a long week hey hey hey i'm
free marketplace of ideas bro
this is the marketplace of ideas i mean
obviously i would confront him on issues
that need to be talked about right it
wouldn't be just like a
yeah i mean you you've always been good
about that i mean the funny thing is
that
the what you were just talking about
with the whole keem villain origin story
of you leaving that comment like you
were saying similar things in that
podcast to his face that's the thing
that i always thought was so silly i was
hostile to keemstar right yeah in that
podcast which like he was fine then but
then you made a pin to comment and all
of a sudden it wasn't fun it literally
didn't make anything didn't make any
sense and even afterwards he was he went
on immediately to like
rant about us in a stream
right and um
i think i tried to talk to him directly
right
to chill him out to chill him out and
just be like
it's nothing that serious
um
and he was like nah nah oh he was so
rude tried having super rude in the dms
that's when he made her cry because he
he was actually just so [ __ ] rude and
disgusting to her i've never seen
anything because like
five minutes before then when we met we
were like we were polite to him we were
not you know it wasn't like
i don't know i mean yeah we have we've
criticized him before and i that wasn't
anything new but we were
polite and willing to have a
conversation it's funny when i posted
the original keemstar episode a lot of
comments were like ethan was so rude to
him
one of the first opening lines there's i
think it's the third sentence you say is
how does it feel to be the most hated
man on the internet
right yeah
and he said something like well how does
it feel to meet me in person you're like
it's whatever
well my theory with having keemstar on
was like
the the marketplace of ideas thing where
it's like i can talk to people i don't
like that's interesting
right yeah i mean that's
it's something that you've done
consistently and you know
that's nothing new for ethan
you've had a lot of like uh former
enemies on the show
yeah jake paul on right joy salads on
yeah that would be like i had jake paul
on so it was a fairly i'd so flow on but
the jake paul one was were particularly
contentious right yeah and um it's like
jake paul losing his mind because i
would go well i don't like him it's like
yeah obviously i mean with her boob
coming out yeah it was it was obvious to
everyone it wasn't coming on as like our
best friend
right it was never really like softball
either like you would
i mean uncomfortably so sometimes so you
know and and and ever but the problem
was that ever since that day he's like
lied and gone out of his way to
literally ruin our life like he has made
it his stated goal since then to
financially and personally and
professionally hurt us and so
obviously that's not what i criticize
him for
uh because he's done actual harm in the
world right um but yeah he's the worst
elo my favorite tweet you've ever put
out was when you did the acronym for
[ __ ]
oh they're crosstick that was that's
just
yeah
that was [ __ ] phenomenal
which was defending lena my wife yeah
yeah
oh yeah
yeah
um can we do a poll i just want to be
can i ever have jason on the show no
people are already saying don't roll it
okay good so vote i'm just curious i
want to get i'm i haven't invited
eventually i haven't talked to him i'm
just curious it's not even to say that
he'd be willing to yeah and i don't even
know if he'd be willing to i'm just
curious on saying not only the sad stuff
that he still hasn't talked about
there's also the tana stuff because he
was preying on her
and she was underage right
so first of all put up the poll but the
thing is like having someone on
obviously those are issues that i would
confront him on so he would need to talk
about those things to come on this show
i have a feeling this is going to be a
blowout but might as well just do it
right i mean i'm really curious i'm
really i'm genuinely serious here we go
this isn't something that's happening
i'm just i'm curious what's
i mean you had jeff on look how that
went
yeah exactly that was not
a favorable interview for jeff
putting it lightly
all right i just started it oh this is
interesting
oh so it's it's close how is it that
every poll is like 50 50. it's
weird
it's odd
uh
hmm
so far
the yeses are winning
edging out
well i mean it's not by can't play the
triumphant sound until
a little bit more time passes yeah thank
you there we go
all right the the votes are coming in
that's a lot of no's though
very divisive like you don't want to
have someone on that half of the people
watching are going to be
pissed i see people saying like i will
not watch it all caps
but you know the conversation would be
interesting as [ __ ]
would it though yeah because he would
have to talk about all that [ __ ] i
wouldn't let him get it back nothing's
good at professional
professional confrontation so yes thank
you exactly i think that's probably
where a lot of the yeses are coming from
it's not a it's not a puff piece it
would be right which again this is all
hypothetical and like why would jason
even subject himself yeah
okay can you can hit that you can hit it
interestingly never dance i expected it
to be to side to the nose but look at
that the yeses are edging out a little
bit
well uh anyway it's not even on the
table i was just genuinely curious what
people would think if i did that sure i
haven't talked to him
but he does follow the podcast so hi
[Laughter]
you know
crazy though
i think blanks would be more interesting
to watch you think you think well okay
well people watch a bla i mean there's
nothing wrong with blanks right there's
no controversy around him other than
faze being sued for
like various reasons hit me up let's
talk about it
let's have a look
not him personally but yeah also if
hassan does like blanks then you know i
like i don't i don't want anyone i don't
know that he does like it's kind of like
an ironic thing i think oh it is but i i
can't maybe not maybe not i don't know
but
i'll text him
do you like facebook and the clips that
i've seen it seems like he likes him in
the way that we
like some people for providing us with a
lot of laughs and humor but but maybe he
really does like them i don't know it's
hard to tell yeah it's hard to tell
do you like faze blanks
anyway so that's that a lot to unpack
there people
are you [ __ ] high oh you sound like
that's that quickly you gotta
yeah
and that keemstar going it was like oh
right
agreeing with him you're the maestro
here you go 21 hours ago petition for
jason nashville on the podcast
there's a petition ela
it's a tweet with 26 likes it's a
petition we have to obey it the word is
out
oh bonus keemstar hilo
oh this is this is actually so [ __ ]
good
this [ __ ] tweeted this
he goes youtube shorts and it's all
thirst traps
and then everyone's like dude you know
that it's based on your algorithm right
and interestingly these are all kind of
the girls he's trying to connect with on
instagram yeah so
yeah that happened
dude
such a self-report
powerful poster it's amazing it really
is can i just say this because people
are saying oh it was tick tock feet that
was an account i had for eight hours
he's had this year look how fast you
were able to get 15 years look how fast
you were able to get that algorithm
going
yours wasn't
but he's had his youtube account for
what 15 years like how long
it's tailored to what he's
go ahead
you guys keep saying it's off my
activity
but i don't watch shorts a liar and my
normal youtube vid watching recommended
is drama related yeah but it's not
related to youtube watching [ __ ] also
i was like i don't watch shorts and i
went there and i my feet didn't look
like this brother do you have to do it
on the phone app i'm trying to see like
yeah
i guess it's phone only
yeah mine are all attack on titan
that's no surprise
top comment he's so close to realizing
that him and his audience our audience
are [ __ ] creeps and the algorithm
picks up on that
yeah so shout out to the one and only
oh oh no
kim starts writing another letter
oh did we we were not able to get phase
blanks from the back there eh oh you
know what we did that i think we just
had the old version
let's get in the new one because
that's important detail okay
yeah it turns out uh keemstar is writing
another email to susan how do you see
when i go to shorts it just shows me if
like a tick tock like feed i want to see
like yeah that's what i was i was having
trouble finding like a dashboard yeah
you get the suggestion box in the main
feed normal feed
okay almost everything on mine is
related to
um hearts of iron four
uh
here's a basketball thing no thirst
traps yet interesting how'd that happen
here's a conan o'brien thing
skateboarding hmm
weird
weird how that works
yeah that was that was a for sure
self-report
so um anyway when you you could oh
[ __ ]
gila
team starts writing another letter to
susan
and faith banks is in the background on
the couch
dear susan
[Laughter]
today h3
made fun of me again
he called me keemsteen
[Music]
the difference between me and epstein
the only difference between me and
epstein
is a billion dollars
[Music]
and ethan knows that
and i consider that
bullying and harassment
susan i'm begging you please
you must erase ethan the bully off the
platform
my friend banks even almost said that he
thinks ethan is funny
[Music]
it was so upsetting
dear susan
faith banks
betrayed me can you please remove him
like keemstar had leafy removed
sincerely yours truly daniel kim
this is urgent an urgent message
thank you
[Music]
yeah
she's got a whole pile of letters from
keemstar on her desk
um up next
shane dawson back in the news eh
oh
he apparently he's planning a comeback
really
interesting apparently the rumor is he's
planning a comeback about free brittany
which people are like dude you have no
right to talk about that
not your story
yeah
how do people know that he said it is it
room how do people know that or maybe i
think
maybe he just feels a connection because
they're both musicians and he just
dropped the hottest track of the year
right i'm getting to that
i don't know if he actually said
anything about that but he is he like
slowly
started being in ryland's vlogs more and
now he's like entirely in them
so i think that he's like getting more
comfortable
and jeffree star said his next video
we'll have shane in it
it's their first online collabs that's
like the suit that's like the villains
the villain super group
shane jeffree star james charles and
keemstar
all get together
what do you do
who do you call
yeah well anyway shane's spotify got
hacked
and somebody uploaded a pretty fire
track called i [ __ ] my cat
do we know it was hat
well are you saying that shane uploaded
it
it's on his account what chance do we
have that it was hacked
right i mean i guess we don't know for
sure but here here's shane dawson i
[ __ ] my cat
by lil radio gamer
and it's pretty fire actually
uh did were we able to capture that
because it was removed this morning yeah
there's a link there should be a link in
there yeah it was up for like a full 24
hours or more it had it had quite a few
streams too didn't it yes
do you remember how many had like
several hundred thousand
well i don't think it got quite to that
amount but but
yeah so i wasn't we were kind of bopping
to this
yeah so this
can you crank it a little bit
[Music]
pretty good i know i was saying like
that's the best track on this spot on
spotify by far
can this get claimed
claiming this [ __ ]
nobody's claiming this
[Music]
[Music]
no way
he's just playing along
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i still genuinely believe shane did
[ __ ] his cat
i genuinely do still believe that
with peace and love
you know but some i'm actually shane
dawson's music may actually get claimed
which is a shame
i didn't know shane made music but man
it is [ __ ] brutal dude
you think it's gonna get claimed
probably right yeah probably yeah
youtuber music they're like thank you
yeah
shane dawson music
super love yeah this one's really bad
[ __ ] i want to play it so bad you guys
here maybe i'll just play a short little
blip and it's totally serious like this
is one hundred percent is it old hot 100
oh yeah it's from twenty two oh i [ __ ]
my cat is number one on the hot 100
knock little nos x right off the top
spot wait weeks on chart 11 that doesn't
make sense you guys is this an edit
i'm hearing cam giggles
[Laughter]
anyway here i'll give you a a quick
excerpt from super love
[Music]
here yeah try from here
um
i'm so tired of youtubers like thinking
they're [ __ ] pop stars i just want to
kill myself already and stop just stop
bro just because it just doesn't entitle
you to do this [ __ ] i mean this is not
okay
it is it's not okay
you don't get to be a don't get to be a
[ __ ] pop star
because you have a popular youtube
channel it's just not okay
stop it
[Music]
you can't do this this is not okay
back me up this is [ __ ] up this is an
affront against god himself it's [ __ ]
up
i mean it's just like dude
stop it
i don't know the jake paul christmas
song he's probably so much joy
but i don't think jake okay i don't
think jake is actually trying like this
is an earnest attempt of shane to be a
pop star and that to me is sick
sick
but jake paul jake paul christmas song
is clearly i don't think he's trying to
do anything but sell merch with it to
his credit
you know
all i want for christmas is my jake paul
merch this unboxed
and by the way no claim shout out we
watched this many times
do you really it's in your mix it's like
my version of mariah carey that's all i
want for christmas
man these were the days weren't they
yeah there was no boxing there was no
[ __ ]
right
[Music]
and just because we haven't uh
watched any of these in a while logan
paul made a combating
christmas song
to sell merch also explicitly
and um
man it was also really good i don't know
bro he said he wanted to do it what do
you mean he wouldn't do it santa said he
won't deliver the maverick merch this
christmas bro why would he not deliver
maverick merch this year it's not as
much in the game oh no broca's santa
yeah santa for sure i got a message for
santa ready relay this
[ __ ] santa
um dude
that was
do you think it's messed up that he was
friends with this dwarf and he always
like he like cast him as like he made
him dress up as a elf
i mean i'm not gonna get offended for
his friend i'm just saying like
what do we think about that do we know
that they were friends yeah yeah no he
didn't know if he was like an actor or
something no he's his homie apparently
evan
he's like call me you he's like all
right
evan you're going to play the elf
that's baby you seem like you have
thoughts i mean that was sort of the
character in every one of his uh videos
with logan i feel like that's pretty
messed up yeah
bro
he did move out so apparently his life
wasn't that great he went back
this was even back when you could say
[ __ ] in the first 15 seconds
you can't even censor it oh wow
censoring doesn't work doesn't matter it
doesn't change anything damn
so this video would have been like
straight up 88 million views yeah dude
he was a phenomenon back then
gp coming at you oh okay it's so cringy
bro like i'm sorry but like dude you ca
you walking around like that it's just
embarrassing
probably because your parents hate you
bro
22 christmases i've never heard from
santa yeah your parents [ __ ] don't
like you dude
your dad's out
because i met mrs claus
damn he just said he [ __ ] mrs claus
dude
according to the little people
of america
preferred little person no he's a dwarf
though that's his you could say dwarf
i remember watching a documentary and
it's the it's called dwarfism and i
thought that the guy said they preferred
dwarf but then i'm looking it up right
well not every little person is a dwarf
first of all so right our dwarf right
right right that's an offensive term no
just some they it says that the
consensus is they don't prefer they
prefer
little people because dwarfism sounds
more like uh you're defining them by
their condition rather okay little
people
that's [ __ ] up we love our little
people don't we folks terrific people
i
i always say this song is not as good no
it's not it's too tryhard jake's just
like i'm here to sell the [ __ ] merch
anything else he's at least he's direct
although the course is really hacky on
this one so i can get to that
i mean it's important
certified bob
yeah those were the days man those were
the [ __ ] days
for the absolute days my friends i miss
those days simpler times
yeah i mean logan paul's uh
breakaway song for me was always you're
my hero
yeah that's the best one by far
you know like empire
i'll pull it up i don't give a [ __ ]
this is to me
it's what oh old
it's old news but it's so good
let me just pull up the martin luther
king part
yeah so this kid was apparently a
and
fan
brought him out to
make a music video
[Music]
this is it
just the martin luther king part
[Music]
oh [ __ ] he died bro looks like a debt
like a memorial okay enough of that time
to start making some sense back to the
hero stuff let's talk future tense yeah
in 13 to 20 years we'll both be
president so if you talk smack we'll
call the secretary of defense not to
mention secretary defenseman
and yes i'm aware that my rhymes are
super intelligent it's cause i'm in the
zone i'm an avatar in my element i'm a
run
[Music]
so i went and made a song about him
twice song about the price no that is
really nice hit me up if you ever need
advice you're right and here dude takes
the mavic merchandise
everybody needs someone to idolize can
someone find them okay
bro that mean just find the mlk part and
i'll move on i mean jesus christ i'm
looking for it
here i think this is it
no
no it's at 1
005.
oh [ __ ] that was our early take huh okay
here we go
[Music]
look at martin luther king no i'm not
saying that this little dude is martin
luther king but
you're not
i'm not saying that he's not it's not a
sure thing he might be mlk
this dude might be mlk
come on people all right i'm enough
everybody's gp's up angry at me i'm not
i will never get sick of that
you want to order food ela they're
taking a poll on discord
we got a poll going or i just saw
someone ask yeah so there's that we love
it uh shout out to the families of
everyone involved this is a story i'm
really happy about too
facebook
tragically i'm so sorry to say
is pausing work
on the instagram kids app
wait facebook now
or is it instagram well facebook owns
instagram right but they were going to
do like a facebook kids or instagram
instagram kids instagram kids i know and
everyone's like
the creepiest disgusting idea ever oh my
god and i thought that was the end of it
but the [ __ ] president
of instagram made a video
so here facebook announced that it's
pausing instagram kids projects in order
to work with parents experts and policy
makers to demonstrate the value and
needs for this product just drop it bro
there's gonna be eighty percent [ __ ]
predators on there and twenty percent
parentless kids
that that is just and james charles
the ig kids app has had backlash wow so
this isn't just like internet backlash
44 state attorney generals asked
facebook to abandon the project
it's socks wow and a request from a
democratic lawmaker asked for more
details about the project the instagram
team said it was building the app to get
around the problem of kids accessing
instagram without parental permission
yeah i mean you guys just want to farm
their data you sick [ __ ] you freaks
it's so sick these people are straight
up evil psychos
and anyway here's the head of instagram
adam
mazzari
uh he actually put out a video put his
face
out there
and defense of instagram kids wow he's
saying we're pausing it but i believe
we've been forced to pause this but i'm
believing it and i'm gonna make it
happen
this guy put his face on the [ __ ]
internet on this project you [ __ ] you
are sick dude wow
listen to this [ __ ] guy socks
yeah james is the only one devastated by
this and this guy you may have heard of
a project called instagram kid
it's
go ahead douche
god you're these people are evil social
these this guy this man is evil
ultimately it's all going back to zach
right oh for sure
he's still in charge
for sure this is the fall guy i guess
sucks like put your [ __ ] face out
there or you know what happened to your
family
part of a project called instagram kids
the idea was a version of instagram that
is designed to be safe for tweens
now don't say twins don't you don't get
to say twins
coming out of his mouth it just doesn't
feel right what does he mean by that
it's like tweens uh betweens young
teenagers yeah like 11. it's like 11 to
13. yeah okay you don't get to say twins
bro oh okay genius how do you verify
that there's only kids on the app
why how do you prevent sick [ __ ]
predators from going on there and using
it as the spank bank you know that's all
it's going to be so you what do you
think
we already all determined how [ __ ] up
this app is already depressing them dude
you are sick dude oh i [ __ ] despise
this dude
you're straight for me that we're going
to pause our work on the project but i
want to be very clear i still strongly
believe that it's the right thing to do
you
use it why does they think that anybody
cares what you think i know i can't get
over that he put himself out there like
this so it has to be better to give
parents the option to give their tweens
a version of instagram that was designed
with them in mind that it was designed
to be safe for those between 10 and 12.
one where
there are no ads
where there are parental controls where
there's age-appropriate content where
they can supervise and shape the how
about they don't use your app you sick
twisted [ __ ] i know you're just farming
their data bro experience in meaningful
ways deciding how much time their kids
can spend on instagram who they can
follow and who they can message then the
alternative which is to rely on
companies like ours to verify the age of
people who don't yet even this is like a
failed um pitch on shark tank it's like
you're you're proposing a
a product for something that nobody
wants there's no need for this nobody
wants
kids so young having their own instagram
we already don't want them on instagram
exactly like what are you talking about
and he goes he goes otherwise you have
to you have to rely on companies like us
to verify their age it's like whoa what
are you gonna do on instagram kids why
are we going to rely on you for anything
with kids i don't want to rely on you
for anything i have to do with my life
at all [ __ ]
you
just to rely on companies like ours to
verify the age of people who don't yet
even have ideas
now how you can do it on instagram kids
then
step back i'm going to take that time to
talk and listen to parents
safety experts and researchers and get
to more consensus about how exactly to
move forward no don't move forward we're
also going to take some of the work that
we did for instagram kids specifically
parental controls and bring them to
teens more broadly we've seen
competitors do similar work even for
those under 13 specifically youtube and
tick tock and we've talked to parents
all around the world and we hear
consistently
that they're looking for more ways to
supervise and shape the experience their
children have online and on social media
now these are just two steps
for us
can you also talk about the data that
you guys have that kids are being more
depressed now because of instagram
preach it
right let's talk about that data that
you already have right actually i have
that up next you want to go over that
responsibility i'm trying to do the best
we can by the instagram community
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you don't move forward with it all
you care about is farming their data and
you don't care that you're putting them
at risk for both depression and
predators
[ __ ]
on you know it's just it's such a bad
idea
also here's another as either was
referencing facebook is aware of
instagram's harmful effect on teenage
girls leak reveals what about that one
you s this guy is
oh my god these people are so evil
facebook has kept internal research
secret for two years
three three years that suggests
instagram makes body image issues worse
for teen girls
and then and then hard cut to this guy
being like we firmly believe this is the
right thing to do
since 2019 staff at instagram i've been
studying the impact of the product on
its younger users
oh my god they have a whole leaked
presentation
what the [ __ ]
here this is all leaked by the wall
street journal
teen girls body image and social
comparison on instagram and exploratory
study
here i'll read the the bullet points we
make body and we make body image issues
worse for one in three teen girls
32 percent of teen girls said that when
they felt bad about their bodies
instagram made them feel worse
wow i love how they're just they're just
passing that around like interesting
what can we do with this this is our
workplace everybody they're like this is
a great opportunity to sell diet diet uh
diet programs this could be a really
good marketing dollar for us
this is the depression dollar is a very
strong dollar for us to go after
actually
and now that they're depressed this is a
perfect time to sell them a product
because our research also shows that
when they're depressed they make
emotional decisions so they're more
vulnerable fair this is actually a huge
marketing opportunity for us
teens blame instagram for increase in
the rate of anxiety and depression this
reaction was unprompted and consistent
across all groups this is a huge
marketing opportunity for us we find
that when teenagers are experiencing
anxiety or depression we can sell them
almost anything
right
so we're we want to turn the we actually
what we should do is make an entire app
for kids to turn this up as much as
possible and the funnel is going to be
exceptional our research shows that we
can sell them anything when they're in
this state
mark zuckerberg claims social media was
more likely to have positive positive
mental health effects you
on the meat show why is this guy such an
evil piece of [ __ ]
i don't know i mean and everybody's
talking about it i saw this on cnn
and they're showing this and and then at
the same time they're showing zuck in
interviews
saying we don't have any real data to
support um that there's any problem with
you know effects
according to this he says that actually
the effect is positive on mental health
and that too yeah but even like that
intuitively we all know that's not true
of course but then they actually have
like they do have yeah
he lied yeah he outright lied
i just feel like caring it's crazy and i
don't know at what point can the
government do something well they need
to be these they need to be regulated
but um just imagine on a human level
like not only him but all the top
executives there that are aware of all
this stuff not caring about it
they all i guess drank the kool-aid
right for sure anyway here's a little
preview of what uh what's going on in
instagram kids
actually farming embryos uh for what
looks like
uh electricity possibly so
i can understand why some of the
attorney generals wanted a little more
information before this launched
you know
yes according to mark they're having
positive mental health effects
uh
in may adam mazzari this [ __ ] we just
showed who's in charge of instagram said
he has seen research suggesting effects
on teenagers mental health was was
probably quite small
you and the tits you [ __ ]
yeah you don't get to be in that
position unless you're like kiss the
boot of zuck
yeah like this guy is just the worst man
the most concerning finding was that
among users who reported suicidal
thoughts
thirteen percent in the uk
and six percent in the us traced them
back to instagram
this is a fantastic marketing dollar we
find that when when kids are
experiencing suicidal thoughts we can
sell them pretty much anything we can
sell them snuggies in this moment where
they're looking for comfort we can sell
them diet pills
we can even sell them
some of the [ __ ] you see on instagram is
like the worst products like you could
we found that we found that teenage
experiencing suicidal thoughts
their increased sales in um
and uh my pillow goes up uh 50 so that's
a huge marketing opportunity for us
it's just crazy for me because even
me as an adult
i still get depressed from instagram
yeah and i'm thinking like what it's
gonna be insane for kids who are like or
you know teenagers whatever like for
sure who are like dating super insecure
they're insecure they're don't know they
don't
100
yeah
i was 12 when instagram came out and
everybody got it and it changed
everything really mm-hmm
everybody had like new identities that
they were trying to build it was super
weird what do you think about these guys
saying that uh it has
a positive effect on mental health
definitely not um
i feel like instagram was created
obviously to like share moments
and it
kind of got ruined while
it was growing and that's what it's
turned into so i don't necessarily think
it's instagram's
fault at the beginning but they're not
handling it super well
that's probably before facebook bought
it
yeah that's true
yeah when facebook bought it they're
like how can we make these teens more
suicidal we find that's a great
marketing dollar
data shows that suicidal twins are
actually spending more money how can we
make them more suicidal mark
zuckerberg's in the lab
another transatlantic study found that
more than 40 percent of instagram users
who reported feeling unattractive said
the feeling began on the app about a
quarter of the teenagers who reported
feeling not good enough said it started
on instagram damn
let's go mark zuckerberg
in 2017 young minds in the royal society
for public health published research
singling out instagram as having the
most negative effect impact on young
people's mental well-being on all social
media let's [ __ ] go dude
we gotta do something with this guy
um
this video is just too good
which one this guy
being like i firmly believe this is the
right thing to do you may have heard of
a product this guy needs to be kids
the idea was a version of instagram that
is designed to be safe for tweens you
know what shame dude shame i want this
man to be shamed that it's the right
thing to do
it has to be better to give parents the
option shame their tweet shame this
what's this guy's twitter account it's
like uh
okay i don't want to get i don't want to
get it yeah i don't want you
i i mean he deserves it but i'm not
going to do it i don't want to brigade
him but
maybe on my free time
shame apparently um
the uh the whistleblower for all of this
um
is gonna be testing in front of uh
testifying in front of senate and it's
gonna be on uh 60 minutes this weekend
oh wow
the pressure is definitely mounting i'll
be watching that
uh what's the what is this video elo you
recommended i don't know everybody keeps
saying in the chat watch the video
vinsta what's finsta finster's fake
instagram
it's where like
i think a few years ago kids started
making finnstas i have one it's like
when you
it's it's private and it's just for your
like friends and you just post like
funny it's like a real
social media yeah it's like fake
instagram so wait what's the video but
they're saying what yeah the video abs
watching it right now i think it says
will you commit to ending finsta and
it's
it looks like a town hall meeting or
something
hey i'm just trying to make sure this is
it
but
i'm guessing it is will you commit to
ending fidsta what the [ __ ] here i'll
watch this some old ass will you commit
to crusty [ __ ]
will you commit to ending finn stuff oh
yeah the congressman doesn't understand
he doesn't he doesn't know anything
you can tell bro i cannot get over the
fact that our country is run by crusty
old [ __ ] men that don't have the
first thing about technology rules our
whole society yeah i mean
we need people to understand the world
we live in miss uh with all respect mr
bloom whatever the [ __ ] you gotta resign
dude just literally resign you just said
can we end finsta
they think it's a product got it
i gotta enjoy this
this reminds me here will you commit to
ending finn stuff
senator again let me explain we don't
actually we don't actually do
do finnsta
what pinsta refers to is young people
setting up a account where they okay
listen
senate hearings is not a place to
explain basic concepts to old [ __ ] and
the senate i just sent you you need to
educate yourself you have this
opportunity to grill a facebook
executive and she like you couldn't be
more softball she's educating grandpa on
what fence does this is a shame to our
country
it's it's embarrassing bro
i bet he's got some big old giant [ __ ]
tits there's another one here dan this
was from a few years ago it just
immediately reminded me of uh when
the guy asked the ceo of google how to
fix his iphone no
okay i'll get to that i did so many
workers uh katrina uh katrina donated 20
bucks thank you i got instagram at 12
as my friends had it one of them fell
victim to grooming and a lot of us found
depression and thin spo accounts
that triggered eating disorders
which prompted calorie tracking apps to
be promoted to us wow
you know i was joking but somehow
you know that it's true
yeah they talked about in that um
documentary series that came out
recently yeah like that we talked about
i guess it was actually like a year ago
but it was like about facebook and how
its algorithm works and yeah
it creates these kind of cyclical
marketing loops where the social dilemma
yeah
right
oh you okay i just wrong pipe oh yeah i
know what's wrong with me bro i have
water going down the wrong pipe like
every time i sweat
you got a drinking problem i do
can someone grab me a sodie
third gang thank you so much
anyway let's watch
we've elected someone to congress to be
educated by the facebook executives who
could be answered on a q a page you're
wasting time you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] get out of congress and
let someone who knows what the [ __ ]
they're doing in
may want to have more privacy you refer
to it as privacy from their parents what
what in my interaction with teens what
i've found is that they sometimes like
to have a an account where they can
interact just with their with a smaller
group of friends
vince is one of the viewers actually
vince is one of your
products or services we're not talking
about google or oh my god oh my god you
didn't even listen to what you said
but he doesn't do your homework exactly
it's like you just explained it to us
over in like two seconds i mean
just do your homework i also didn't know
where this guy
i think it's ron wyden
no i think he's a democrat actually get
the [ __ ] out of congress bro yeah you're
wasting time you're talking if i'm right
about that being wrong why not i
apologize with him look it up
well i'm looking at a picture of him but
it
it's hard to tell from the video i'm
pretty sure that's wrong
how can you mistake that face for anyone
well because they all look like that
right
well it says his name here mr bloom
something no that's marcia blackburn
sitting next to him that's not his right
here mister it's hidden by i'm sorry
richard
blum menthol oh
so there you go it's not him i'm looking
at a picture of him though all right
richard blumenthal
a congressman
american lawyer political term
connecticut democratic party is another
democrat
shameful lame disgraceful
this is boomer energy i would expect
from republicans
dude they're all the [ __ ] same you
absolute [ __ ]
failure
he's insisting that he's not wrong
it's facebook correct
vince is slang for for a type of account
okay it's not it's not that type of
account oh my god
you should be i'm not trying to
understand exactly what you're asking
what i can say is that based on what
we've seen in terms of teams using those
kinds of accounts we've actually given
them additional privacy options to to
address to address those kinds of issues
where they want more privacy so they can
have our country
it's like you got this representative
you have the option to talk to her and
this is why you're going to talk to her
about it you never get this chance and
he was a lawyer and connecticut attorney
general that's so scary
yeah i know
but also he's got all this staff how do
you not do your research
this is just an embarrassment i mean
shame on you bro this is facebook we
need to understand what's going on there
we need to hold them to account
and no these [ __ ]
dinosaurs
will not even put in the effort to
understand that's an answer to my
question
yeah well your questions make any sense
[ __ ] he thinks she's dodging yeah
shame
speaking of which here's apparently
uh
as someone asking an apple executive how
does bro i can't this is real oh isn't
stephen king like the straight up white
supremacist
um
stephen
oh steve king
it's like stephen king steve king
stephen
king isn't steve kane been in
controversy
i think so
uh steve king
i am of course
a white supremacist okay so this
congressman representative steve king
has the opportunity to speak to google
ceo
yeah you're right it is uh yes
congressman iphone is made by different
so listen to this oh my god he's asking
the google ceo how to fix his iphone
no
i have a seven-year-old granddaughter
who picked up her phone before the
election
and she's playing a little game kind of
game a kid would play and up on there
pops a picture of her grandfather and
i'm not going to say into the record
what kind of language was used around
that picture of her grandfather but i'd
ask you how does that show up on a
seven-year-old's iphone who's playing a
kid's game
right congressman uh iphone is made by a
different company and so you know i mean
once again the ceo
now the ceo of alphabet does not come
around to congress regularly to testify
you do not this time is valuable and
we're sending buffoons we're sending the
poorly educated
soft-hitting
fools we are sending our [ __ ] fools
to congress and this is the result of
that
of course nobody what what the [ __ ] is
this
it's the typical
yeah i think we actually we watch this
clip and yeah it was like a whole thing
that was mr moneybags that showed up
yeah a guy showed up to this thing and
dressed up as a
monopoly man by the way did you finish
the previous video because i think
someone said it gets worse wait we
didn't i think i don't know version is
there a longer version i'm not sure
it ended whatever we were okay okay but
maybe there's a longer version
i will grab it it might have been an
android i it's just it was a
hand-me-down of some kind
uh so what are you asking you know i got
him i'd i guess
he doesn't even know
specifically but there may be an
application which was being used which
uh had a notification but i'm happy to
understand it better and uh clarify it
for you okay uh thank you for your
testimony not believe in the balance
that's it
i mean this is just this is like just
come to me afterwards and show me your
phone and i'll fix it you know it's kind
of like okay grandpa yeah
but you know it's like
these guys this is why these guys laugh
in the face of
of government regulations and the
congress they don't even understand what
they're doing
these guys come in here and uh
they get a more they get more grilled
they get more their burgers get more
grilled from in and out thank you i
don't know what that means that's good
or bad
[Applause]
thank you thank you
my time
when you were young were you an aim user
a well instant messenger yes i missed
those days man
it was so much simpler aim was social
network
yeah exactly
what's your aim bro
and then skype came around and that was
the big phenomenon for a while i used
dave
really no way yeah you are too young i
had an aim
i had aim and then i had i chat
wow amy just shut down maybe like three
or four years ago i remember
it was
saturday
i have no idea what high chat is and you
guys are making me feel older i never
use that
either um
yeah embarrassing shame on us as a
country
uh we are truly
sending our worst out to represent us
and that's why i'm proud to announce
i'll be running for congress
can you imagine if i tried you know you
know can you imagine the uh commercial
attacks on me oh boy
although to be fair there's there's
people in congress that are just
straight up [ __ ] like yeah i just
don't know racist clan members i don't
know how much that matters anymore well
it probably matters
trying to run as a progressive or
something yeah there's a pretty bad
question
it doesn't matter if you're a
conservative you're like he literally
attended clan members they're like well
that's a plus yeah
great
sir
he was arrested for burning a cross at a
black uh
church great we love that about him
here's the full one apparently this
one's a little longer i went i walked
away for a second so i don't know if you
guys got i think we wanted
critical
ways facebook would like to have
critical ways to acquire
new
older users but facebook also knows that
nearly everything maybe i got to start
from here i want to talk about one major
source of concern for parents
they are finstas you idiot
vince does our fake instagram account oh
so he does know you might want to hear
him out before you call him an idiot
again okay i'll hear him i mean because
this supposedly is a clip that shows
that it's not nearly as bad as what just
well then why'd you send that to me i i
don't who said this to me to make the i
don't want clarification i don't i don't
even know what offense is i didn't ask
for clarification i thought it made them
look dumber all right let's watch it
instas are kids sorry i wasn't paying
attention second accounts
vince's often
are intended to avoid
parents oversight
facebook depends on teens for growth
facebook knows the teens often
are the most
tech savvy in the household unlike me
that
they need or they would like to have
critical
ways facebook would like to have
critical ways to acquire
new older users introducing facebook
also knows
in the united states
has an instagram account it can only add
more users as fast as they
there are new
13
year old
so what facebook
has done is finsters
no in multiple documents facebook
describes these secret accounts as quote
a unique value
proposition
well wait they have it they have nothing
to do with fensters they're just people
right
so he did have the definition but it was
like he didn't understand it whatsoever
he thinks yeah it doesn't make any sense
the way he's described it it's a growth
strategy
and it's not it's not complicated people
make a fake account to share with their
friends it's not even like monthly high
level active user
metric
and that active user metric is of great
interest to your investors to this to
the markets
do you have a question
like
it's another case
of like is he just trying to sound smart
this is like at the book report where
you don't actually have an answer so
facebook claims it's giving tools to
parents to help their kids navigate
social media and stay safe online what
is your question
your marketers see teens with multiple
accounts
as it sounds like he's referring to some
leaked internal documents where they
acknowledge these finstas and they're
saying that this is a good thing
okay propositions let me quote
unique value proposition
and we all know
that means
finstas
you're monetizing
kids deceiving their parents
you make money
when kids deceive so his question is
will you commit to ending finsters it's
like
okay that wasn't helpful anyway thank
you
all right let's move on to alex jones
baby
oh briefly because i want to mention
this was his thought with us on ila but
you may not have heard the news
alex jones lost his lawsuits in the
sandy hook thing
the [ __ ] got to pay up wow but
it may surprise you why a judge didn't
actually rule against him he failed to
respond to the lawsuits what after years
of the judge
warning him
and
calling him out he just failed to
respond so
it was a default judgment against him
alex jones has lost two of several
lawsuits
filed against him by sandy hook victims
after he routine routinely failed to
comply with requests
to produce documents related to his
involvement in spreading lies
about the deadly shooting
jones
who is now on his seventh lawyer in
these cases
oh my god
isn't that just darling he had years to
provide documentation requested by the
court including internal company emails
so during discovery he just never
responded it seems like
i wonder what do you think
well either the the i think that
the documents would be so
damning that providing them would just
be a sure loss or worse or worse you
know in the uh and public
it would just ruin him
so they either made a calculated
decision
not to provide it or
that that has to be there's no other
explanation
yeah i can't think of another reason why
he would do that or he's just
incompetent i don't think so he's a
shrewd businessman
and he's consulted with eight different
lawyers
so i think what happened and i think
what happened why he went through so
many lawyers because he was desperate to
find a way not to send these documents
right and during discovery
uh you have to send documents
so
basically i think that yeah what what he
would have had to
give them would be so damning
that he would rather lose the lawsuit
than face the consequence of whatever
they were talking about behind the
scenes
well we have a statement from alex jones
infowars
eighth attorney
the trial court's entry of a default in
those cases is stunning
it takes no account of the tens of
thousands of documents produced by the
defendant the hour spent sitting
for depositions and the various horn uh
test uh statements
what's more these cases are currently
before the united states supreme court
where we have asked to review the texas
supreme court denial of motion to
dismiss we are
we are distressed by what we regard as a
blatant abuse of discretion by the trial
court we are determined to see that
these cases are heard on the merit
nothing less than the fundamental right
to speak freely is at stake
yeah i'm pretty sure you can't incite
uh violence and harassment on based on a
lie or truth is it not overstatement to
say that the first amendment was
crucified today bro all you had to do
was turn over discovery that sounds like
an overstatement
it could be wrong but
well anyway uh good friend of alex jones
joe rogan actually
he wanted the comments was
standing by to share his thoughts on
this uh groundbreaking
verdict so
are we ready do we have him yeah i can
patch him in hold on one second
uh here let me bring him in right now
[Music]
it's fine so i mean obviously alex jones
has lost um i know he's a friend of
yours what do you think about that
that's a horrible thing that they do
they smash that kid into the water and
pick them up by their arms and smash
them down in the water again and they do
it a bunch of times
then they cut his dick every year also
kids this has happened multiple times
these kids have been circumcised by a
traditional you know what is it
with a rabbi and the rabbis had herpes
and they've transferred it because the
rabbi has to suck the kid's dick yes
okay they still do that and they still
defend it it's a traditional way of
doing it yeah wash your dick you dirty
[ __ ] all this is spreading from you
yelling at a kid to wash his dick i mean
that hardly seems appropriate he'd be
like okay inside yoga is bad but what
about park yoga is that okay all right
you know what i'm okay to do parking lot
i asked about alex jones you're talking
about so you have these people very
inappropriate disturbing things yeah
idiots they're so dumb they keep getting
adjusted going on vacation when they're
telling everybody to stay home how crazy
that is all right yeah
and be in a condo in cabo and listen you
can we can't relax you know don't try
i'm sorry stay away from people all
right
take care
yeah that guy can never stay on track
you know
i don't know if we should take his calls
anymore right
[Laughter]
yeah i mean the guy can't stay stick to
the conversation yeah
i don't know why
some of the [ __ ] he said was just wildly
inappropriate yeah that was [ __ ] up
yeah i couldn't really get an answer
about the alex jones thing
um speaking of joe rogan ela he lost his
number one spot in the world on spotify
where he's exclusive to really and it's
made the [ __ ] carl jacobs from mr
beast made of the minecrafter
made a podcast banter these guys are so
[ __ ] popular wow
they passed joe rogan on his own turf
and i doubt they're even exclusive to uh
spotify oh yeah i don't think so
joey boys falling to the wayside man
that's crazy actually it's more
impressive about them yeah but i've
heard that joe's uh popularity has been
following lately
i mean so many people watched him on
youtube
i
like yeah you know he had to have shed a
substantial amount of audience when he
went exclusive on you know it's
interesting because
it's free on on spotify but just the act
of having to
go there sign up and all that it's just
their video player sucks it's it's and
then people are on youtube they want to
they're on youtube they see the episode
yeah he definitely lost a lot
we're coming for a spot
history's coming at you we're coming for
you joe joey boy
so
shout out to carl
carl the new podcasting king of the
world
banter
shout out to his family huh
you okay oh look at him
you feeling okay buddy
yeah he keeps coming to us maybe he
needs to go i don't know shannon do you
want to try to take him out maybe they
have to go
potty look good
[Music]
you wanna go for a walk
so anyway yeah there he goes he looks
happy happy boy
um another important update you guys how
long we've been going dan
oh uh two hours so we got free eli you
helped me decide you're back
free brittany or devious licks challenge
well britney's in the title and
thumbnail
so
probably should talk about her at least
a little bit brittany devious licks and
david dobrik
if you still care about those kind of
things
the licks challenge sounds interesting
all right let's do but let's do it all
did we end up ordering food
not yet i asked if you guys wanted
mediterranean
do you have an opinion
can you shop i can't you can't decide
get something we can eat
we have uh you guys it takes me too long
to decide on food it's not something i
can do live
um do you want me to just
do whatever yeah okay cool
well
oh my mom's there today nice
yeah shout out to mama klein
i'm sorry treader
all right so free britney's free
britney is we did it we did it
we freed up
guns in the air for brittany
we did it we did it it was us stop it's
just in the air for brittany
guns in the air for brittany did you
feel any salt that's something
drama
britney's free and we free britney
i like to think that we had at least a
majority part in having that happen what
do you all say
like 90
i mean it's only a matter of
time since all the crazy media coverage
but i'm happy to say
i think well here let me read the
updates jamie is gone her dad after
hearing both sides the judge conceded
that the current situation is untenable
it reflects a toxic environment which
requires the suspension of jamie spears
thank you
you know if instagram is looking for a
new executive this guy might fit right
in with child exploitation and
everything he's
perfectly hits their philosophy
his lawyers released a statement all
spears wanted was the best for his
daughter yeah right if mr spears wants
to terminate the conservatorship
and believes that she can handle her own
life mr really spears believe that's
what she should do yeah it's not like
she hasn't been saying that not like
been 12 years or something i don't know
liar okay his pockets are aligned though
he's good
brittany and her lawyers have selected a
conservator why is this just ended
they're now getting a new conservator oh
yeah they selected but at least it's
someone who's qualified yeah someone of
her choosing
though another hearing is being set
to consider the termination this
conservatorship [ __ ] is so [ __ ] like
they can't end it
but
at least she got to choose someone
qualified no i agree but the whole
notion that she needs a of life
babysitter is just insane
the only thing i can say is maybe we
don't know everything
i don't know i mean but the application
of a conservatorship in this
in this scenario is like practically
unheard of it's for people who are like
senile yeah
well anyway
she's well on her way to freedom i
wonder what's going to go down because
she's been posting like some raunchy
[ __ ] on instagram like this girl's
itching to be free we we put some uh in
there we censored them but is this the
video what's in this or is it something
else no that's just a
series of like damn some of the [ __ ]
she's been posting on instagram is like
let's
this was from instagram
didn't she ha she was censoring like
that she put tiny little flower emojis
posted on instagram instagram's like
[ __ ] it she's brand new yeah you're
gonna ban brittany
how many likes did that post get cause
like that that that's as good as
instagram post gets from britney spears
i mean you don't really get content
coming out that fresh anywhere it's so
good jesus
[Music]
this is all recent eh
[Music]
she got over three million likes
we need to get a more likes than that
jesus i agree
britney spears instagram let's take a
look
well wait wait oh is it too hot for tv
yeah that's why we blurred it it may be
too hot okay you can check it out first
don't show it on my screen so i guess
some people are saying that they don't
end it yet because of the documents
because if it ended now
jamie wouldn't have to turn them over
so they i guess they're
it's part of a strategy probably not for
real
did you see this i did it was on my feed
that is like
but i mean brittany is free baby so many
like can you post that on instagram
though yeah so many stars
post that all the time like you can even
see a little nip though look at this
nipples on instagram too i mean you see
nips on instagram you've seen that nips
on instagram
you allow nips on instagram i don't know
if they always allow it but like some
people get i don't know i guess because
they call it art some people can do it
yeah
that flower ain't covering everything
not always again what are they they're
gonna ban britney spears no no no no of
course not
but
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
dude she is out there
it's just i can't believe what i'm
seeing
holy moly
she is out there and living it
oh here we got an update bare nipples on
a photograph of women are off limits
though instagram sam says it makes
allowances for users who make
clear that the display of nudity is
meant as a form of protest or to raise
awareness for a cause she's protesting
she's free britney free britney kitties
she is let's get out of here let's go
let's let's go
free britney and all part of everybody
can i show dick as protest
um
[Music]
you're looking at the policy aren't you
it didn't say dick it just specifically
mentioned nipple it says nipples
we have dick can you find the uh
penis portion of the policy please i'm
looking into it now and if we have some
videos here let's enjoy
finding out uh
is this copyrighted or yeah finding out
jamie spears got suspended during a live
stream
sorry
jamie's gone
kayla they pulled out houses
[Music]
oh this is a good day we're going to
sweat booties
get it
you just gave me a ring it's a special
time
of freedom
all right careful with that music there
zach
slay that [ __ ] is this the whole thing
or is there more
you get that jump high for me
jamie in the face
i'll do this i'll
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but that gives me hope actually because
it sounds like basically she will get it
eventually to end it for sure it sounds
like it's heading that way now that he's
gone i mean
yeah so wait they're delaying it to
get papers from him what paper yes for
the last 13 years i guess
like some kind of accounting of bill i'm
kind of an audit maybe
oh i'd love that delaying or something
he's using the alex jones legal defense
strategy yeah oh just don't turn them
over
i love how the judge used the word toxic
in their uh statement
as a reference
or wink wink
yeah i mean
it's britney [ __ ]
so you the devious licks is a great tick
tock challenge has been going on a shout
out to the fans of those involved
um
this is a weird one
devious licks lick being like when you
nick something when you steal something
one of the things that you do is called
enough
it's like when you lick something it's
just what the kids say yeah
i'll be honest when i first saw devious
licks and tick tock and a lot of it
takes place in the bathroom
and i'm like nope nope because i thought
like urinals and [ __ ] i immediately
bounced that at the devious right yeah
but so i was a little relieved when i
found out they were just stealing dumb
[ __ ]
just because you wouldn't want to watch
it i would watch people nick thumb [ __ ]
but i didn't want to see anyone
okay
so apparently it just got out of control
people started just fleecing
oh the devious looks challenge has
apparently
been youtube
oh
community guidelines we have intervened
um that's when you know the meme's dead
yeah
um
the good stuff is is
the fireworks
it's a graveyard they got them all i
looked at them all yesterday
the wet floor sign let's see what what
kind of graveyard we've got
knit
wow
the devious
is over it's probably for the best
because we would have got god too
right we were showing it here's a whole
bathroom where did they say
tick-tock doesn't give a [ __ ] but but i
mean
you probably shouldn't show it ethan
i mean you're all gonna have
this isn't showing anyone stealing
anyone this one's okay they're just
showing this is the aftermath of the
devious lick challenge because people
were going to bathrooms and literally
just stealing everything look at how
wrecked this bathroom what the [ __ ] is
going on bro come on look at this [ __ ]
yes so stupid it was getting out of hand
yeah a little bit
and this is actually a good one too
that's not related to people stealing
stuff the schools oh my god this one got
removed too i'm telling you it showed
them like they had to start nailing [ __ ]
down and strapping like the soap
dispenser was on the wall and it was
strapped in by metal and [ __ ]
god that is so stupid well in response
to the devious licks
a new trend arise a holy
blissful trend called angelic yields
due to the uproar that the devious licks
challenge started it has progressed into
angelic yields which started with them
bringing items back
but has quickly turned into kids
bringing random objects and gifting the
school with them
so here is the opposite
of the devious licks this is
the holiest of yields this account is
called
so here you go
[Music]
gentlemen's club
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah the tables have turned my friend
it's an angelic place
not only is this oh wow wow
just wholesome but this is genuinely so
much [ __ ] funnier than right stealing
stuff yeah going in and like checking it
out this is
[Laughter]
yeah so that's a whole yield right there
my friend
absolutely and you can't i like that you
can't nick anything from the bathroom
that'd be blasphemy
uh here's a holiest of yield in
another
uh this has always been happening people
say it's just now like sitting on the
tick tock oh for real i didn't why
well yeah i mean people well people
stand alone
specifically for the bathroom
what is their disturbing bathroom paper
towel dispensers that's so like whatever
you [ __ ] can't it for sure has always
been a thing that teenagers do but i
think for a gag or just or just because
to be destructive yeah i mean why not
you're a teenager and you're vandalized
i don't remember my bathroom being
stripped there my school
had a lot of vandalism really really wow
lausd baby we can say he looked like he
had something on the tip of your tongue
i don't know if it was that interesting
my
uncle used to have a school named after
him because he was really old but
anyways he collects
wait wait wait that's why i was waiting
because it's like oh if he's right
your uncle had a school named after him
it's still named after him the michael
berry because he's old not because he's
old that's why i don't want to seem like
i'm talking like but who names the
school after someone for being really
old no he was trying to not brag i know
but it doesn't make sense
to make any sense no that's not just
trying to do it so why is this
after him because he was very prominent
in the community he was one of the first
arab american muslim attorneys really in
the us yeah wow
yeah but
point of my story wasn't about anymore
it was about that all of our friends
would take a [ __ ] on the bathroom floor
and say [ __ ] your uncle's school oh my
god
that was the [ __ ] nice
i just [ __ ] on the memory of a man who
accomplished so much in 90 years yeah
they would show on the floor is like a
joke i don't know my hometown's [ __ ]
it's a joke yeah but like you see
something around what it's a joke people
just [ __ ] on the floor i mean that's the
generous hero
again high schoolers are [ __ ] wild is
there any other prominent figures in
your life you want to give a shout out
to maybe just you baby
thank you right answer only
shout out to his family
literally yeah really shout out to your
family
no yeah i think obviously the
fact that it became a trend
you know multiplied it many times over
the amount of this going on well here's
a holy yield
what is this one uh chilling and
hospital hospitable yield
[Music]
in the bathroom
he's unboxing something for the bathroom
a fridge oh he's stuck in the fridge
i'm just chilling oh that's nice i mean
with peace and love i'm not getting
snacks
where are they getting their money
and a tv
it looks like an old box so maybe
that was just the box from a fridge that
he had in this house
that's beautiful that's what we need
right yeah a dining experience a holy
yield
here we go another bathroom being
blessed
just hit the most angelic yield
[Music]
i'm just somebody's in there cedar
rapids oh
what a match
what a match is this stall bro
i know inspired by stall bro for sure
that's true now that's a holy yield my
friends
no utensils though huh
what are you gonna do with a bowl of
spaghetti
oh there no there's no utensils yeah
that's a devious yield right
uh
mega awesome donated ten bucks uh dad's
a principal mom's a teacher and because
of devious licks the kids were
destroying the bathrooms classrooms
vandalizing everything there's only one
bathroom open with security guards holy
[ __ ] that's insane it got way out of
hand oh my god god
holy god thank you for that anecdotal
mega awesome and it's just so
it's so stupid like i get it stupid
it is funny but like obviously people
take it way too [ __ ] far yeah exactly
and if you work at that school you're
like okay well there's like i could see
people like unscrewing a [ __ ] toilet
yeah and they were like stealing like
the
drinking fountains and stuff it's like
public schools especially like they have
no [ __ ] money they can't replace the
[ __ ] no it's funny
i guess no i acknowledge it's funny i
saw one kid he took the fire alarms
that wasn't removed obviously funny but
like you need fire alarms yeah for
obvious reasons exactly
i just
you know that the inverse to me is so
much funnier
like the the decking out and
beautifying the bathroom well here
here's one last one a angelic yield
uh
[Music]
we're in another bathroom
bathrooms are popular uh
places for
gags
and it looks like we're unboxing a
television here
fantastic
and uh we're just gonna put that right
there
wait do public schools have
sockets in the bathroom that seems kind
of fancy
[Applause]
it's been a long time since i've been in
a public school i guess because my i
feel like the schools were like prisons
bro when i mean the the bathrooms were
like prisons yeah they were pretty rough
where i went you're lucky if the stalls
had doors sometimes oh yeah for sure
in sweden we don't even have like stall
type bathrooms in schools i would never
like go to the bathroom in one of those
oh it's like an individual experience
yeah man you guys have transcended
yeah yeah you are so weird to me you
just don't [ __ ] at school it's not an
option where we come from yeah exactly
you hold it bro you literally you'll get
like [ __ ] disorders growing up in our
schools we don't have also a regular one
hell no no really only the stall
stalls only bro what it
stahl is like it is like uh
like when you're going up public
stall there's the door there's like
three stalls
that's normal yeah right yeah well he's
love is saying you know in scandinavia
and where they've transcended uh they
have
yeah in sweden they have stall they have
private stalls there i mean they've
really like a like a bathroom here like
yeah it's just like they're completely
separated it's just totally separate but
i think yeah that's like five stars yeah
intentional here because the gaps are
always big too just so kids don't mess
around like
i always wondered why is it like that
you can kind of yeah so they don't yeah
okay explain why there's gaps in the
airport then
in the airport same reason probably
probably
yeah actually exactly the same reason
yeah okay well why are there gaps in
every stall everywhere i don't know it's
insane
people can spy on some societies
yeah you know homeless people or
whatever
whatever they're trying to keep out i
used to have to i would go when i had to
[ __ ] at school i would go in the faculty
bathroom i didn't give up how did you do
that i just walked in
i never even thought about doing it i
just i'm just like joker yeah and right
i got going one time and the teacher was
like what are you doing here because it
was in like the staff lounge and [ __ ]
i'm like i straight up said i went to
the bathroom
and that much is obvious i'm like what
are you gonna do like well yeah yeah but
i i never even dreamed that you could
get through but once you're in and
you're [ __ ] nobody's gonna stop you
no he was probably taller than all the
staff so
yeah i didn't look twice well the truth
is i was well trained my bowel movements
like during the school time oh yeah you
would never your body just is why just
because it's gross yeah yeah yeah it's
i'd rather [ __ ] die than should i
from in 13 years from kindergarten to
12th grade i probably went number two at
school like three times i don't remember
doing it once like just emergencies
online i can't remember one time i [ __ ]
yeah i mean you kind of it's like a
window you know you're gonna get home
yeah exactly
the worst is in the morning though like
when it hits you in the morning
even in college there was only one
bathroom i would use and it was like at
the far building on the eighth floor i'm
like oh dude one everybody goes there
visit my buddy at college his his dorm
stalls were so gross
oh my god yeah [ __ ] in the dorm was
bad bad bad bad but that was it man they
said uk stalls don't have the gaps and
no gap on the floor either yeah it
i think it's oh somebody said it's for
medical reasons so if someone passes out
you can see them why the [ __ ] i got a
[ __ ] where people can watch me just for
the few people that are gonna pass out
like i'm sorry america get your [ __ ]
together it's not just america though i
think it's everything you think you said
in the uk people have privacy well that
might just be the uk i don't know it
sounds like in in israel where ila grew
up it was the same way i think so i
think i remember like close the gap let
them die let them die it's not my
problem in uk they mine the gap
i somewhat i was um
i i took a [ __ ] in the macy's a few
weeks ago play easy few weeks ago yeah
all right let me know let me know about
it and uh there was some dude that
looked in
it was very uncomfortable he probably
knew who you are too
one of these
yeah he well he was seeing if the stall
was vacant because you know it's the
back stall well you look at the feet you
don't look at the man he [ __ ] looked
in i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
but wait so was it such an emergency oh
yeah oh yeah exactly i don't know what's
going on in your life you have too many
emergencies though bro well i have ibs
oh
[Laughter]
could it be the keto diet possibly i
just have a horrible stomach people say
funny enough
canada has the gap
yeah let them die well some places here
don't have the medical emergencies if
it's like a really fancy restaurant or
like uh neiman marcus they'll they'll
bring it all the way down they'll give
you the problem and marcus you they have
their own rooms there they don't have
calls that's what i'm saying i'm saying
if it's a
wealthier place or like a nicer scale
place they'll close the gap nordstrom
has no gaps
south africa they're just saving money
on the gap mm-hmm
i just want to see here it doesn't have
stalls so i just want to say sorry about
the mess i made of the macy's bathroom
it was pretty bad that guy knows who you
are
i mean the the toilet was destroyed so
sorry
we didn't ask
never seen a human take such pride in
his [ __ ] so i was gonna say uh
uh yeah so the thing about my college
experience at uc santa cruz
is that the dorms that i were in were
co-gender
we shared bathrooms and showers
with girls and so not only did you have
disgusting bathrooms everyone shared you
would potentially be in there [ __ ]
while a girl was showering that's crazy
and um
i know that's the first time i ever saw
like blood in the toilet and stuff which
obviously that's like you know a
function of biology but it shocked the
hell out of me the first time i saw like
a pool of blood on the bottom of the
toilet
girls are nasty too bro there was like
tampons in the toilet tampons all over
the toilet and there was new dimensions
of disgusting i learned yeah uh by
sharing a bathroom with a bunch of women
in that capacity i
i worked at a restaurant for years and
for the first year that i worked there
i was the host and one of the duties was
to take out all the trash in the
bathrooms and stuff
and
i don't know i don't know if it's
i mean this is anecdotal this was just
one place although a b was just pointing
at me and he knows exactly what i'm
about to say
the women's bathroom was always so
much more [ __ ] up than the men's room
like interesting that is what i've
learned working in a restaurant the
women's bathroom is ten times dirtier i
don't know what it is about this [ __ ]
i've seen in there absolutely
go both away i don't know i'm sure
probably i know what you mean like i've
seen really nasty women's bathrooms but
i also seen the opposite so i don't know
yeah maybe maybe but it was a it was
weirdly consistent
going in there and like the stuff that
you find in the you know they have the
the
sanitary box like in this one can
somebody explain to me this tiny
sanitary box
first of all it's tiny like it's it's
and you gotta touch it to open it yeah
what is this i i've never seen it
outside of the ufo by the way stop bro
just became a super trooper guys yo star
bro shout out to the original let's go
someone caught this
i think those are for privacy issues so
like women shouldn't put it in like an
open trash bag
and have guys and people come in
afterwards that's what i was perhaps i
mean what's the difference between a
trash can with a lid it's the same thing
well it's got blood on it so the blood
is a biohazard you know what we need to
rethink but you got to open it with your
hands and it's tiny i agree it's always
gross
oh it's always full right
like yeah like yeah one person fills it
up with like all that's
maybe it should be like hand censored so
you don't have to touch it
uncensored that would be nice because i
don't want to
walk out of the stall and then use that
i'd rather get rid of
the situation at the time
why isn't there a trash can inside there
is right not always not always but
whether it's only that little tiny box
yeah yeah yeah the tiny box with the
little brown bag yeah that always slips
yeah yes right what is that i don't like
that not a great design one thing one
thing we need to redesign is the toilet
you know the protective cover that goes
on the toilet in public restrooms the
one that always gets stuck to your butt
the seat cover yeah the seat cover yeah
yeah those we need to rethink that
i'm kind of with you on that it is such
honestly i've gotten so good at using
those i feel like because at work
five years of service using those on a
daily basis i got real good it's true
you do kind of get used to it i don't
trust those first of all i take a whole
handful of them i put them in the water
immediately no splash
that's the [ __ ]
that's so bad that is genius though no
you have to do it because splashing on
my ass is not an option i do that too
but i do it with toilet paper
so it's the same this one's thinner it's
nothing it's like nothing is it
you don't need like you don't need a lot
you just need like a few just to cover
the water so that's that's where you get
in
next you take two line them up and what
i do is i rip out the hole
okay take off each piece so it doesn't
and then you rip once you get good at
taking out that center piece clean it
lays nice on the toilet and you're good
okay i always rip the whole thing when i
try to get the center for you you get
good okay question i've done it hundreds
of times what about it sticking to your
ass though well fine just peel it off
what are you going to do that never
happened to me
i only stand up when i'm done [ __ ]
what's your problem i'm saying if you're
there you know it's it's friction and
heat i stand up when i'm done and it
sticks to my ass i peel it off and throw
it in the bathroom but the thing is it
gets stuck though and you got to rip it
off in pieces and that doesn't happen to
me i don't know what the [ __ ] is this is
what you need to redesign what are you
like
when he uh went in his boss's car and
put the rose bomb oh yeah like that's
the only time that was yeah
i got a sticky ass you know
i sent just a four second clip of when i
worked at a restaurant you could hear
someone in the background saying the
girls effed up the toilet again
it was a daily thing yeah
oh yeah yeah
i can't hear
[Laughter]
yeah the girls are gross and also like
the hair in this like you would go to
shower it's a little stall the shower
and um
the hair man the hair i get ptsd from
all the hair
just hair and hair and hair
i hear you
so much hair you guys
hair all over the walls here in the
drain and then dudes jerk off in the
shower and it gets stuck on the hair
guys is that there's always pee on the
toilet seat like men need to not leave
people just sting a pee like you know
it's it's dried up and it's yellow
yellow yeah men not men need to not
leave pee
by no means were the men's rooms you
know nice like i didn't mean to imply
like christine in there and then the
women's room is [ __ ] up but
relatively speaking
on average the women's room was trash
way more
i'll
i'll just say i've been in the bathroom
before and i legit thought someone was
killed in there because of
period blood
is it possible to get period blood
everywhere like somehow it is let me
tell you really it's i mean i've seen
stuff it is
oh my goodness i don't know what's
what's going on that's scary i don't
know but i i know what you're talking
about i'm definitely fine
how does that happen
how does it happen to do when there's
poop like sprayed on right well i
understand explosive diarrhea
how does it get up there i mean how high
have you seen it
i've seen it like on the side of the on
the wall oh my god so i think what
happens there is they don't want to sit
on the bowl
and so they squat and then you know
right yes you're totally right but i
don't know how that happens with the
period unless you can have explosive
periods no
it doesn't work that just seems
uncomfortable to do the squat though
i'm sure it is but yeah they end up
causing way more damage by trying to do
that than uh than if they just sat down
yeah i've researched this but apparently
you can't really catch diseases from
putting your bare ass on a toilet
you can or you can you cannot yeah
i have a fear of that i mean yeah it's
disgusting and not touch it a bunch of
strangers plopping ass in the same spot
that's why we need to rethink the toilet
protector
we need a toilet condom that's what we
need
that sounds good actually
like that would really give you cover
right right i would trust that
one of our mods uh
uh raphael do you guys want to say his
name i don't want to say it
girl ray oh ray
shout out to ray one of our mods i used
to work in a grocery store i had to
clean [ __ ] off of walls ceilings
urinals in my opinion both men and women
rooms were equally gross it was the kids
and older people who caused havoc yeah i
think that's that's likely the case
yeah all the extreme engine
i'm about to die like i can't be [ __ ]
with this [ __ ]
like i'm just in and out dude i i you
know
all right well ending on a high note
there
i guess somebody there's a girl saying
that like with the diva cup which
oh
that explains um but you'd have to take
a diva cup and like splash it on the
wall i don't think it's panic ritual she
said that thing failed her and
and similarly explosion i'm really
curious she just said my diva cup failed
me last period one night i woke up
walked and just an explosion it looked
like someone was murdered
okay so i mean there you go there's
there's a scenario someone
it's some explanation
so wrong now the diva cup is just like a
little
k-cup that you put in
yeah
yeah like that okay eight ounces
what do you want in size
blood boiling
[Music]
[Applause]
would you believe that huh it's the
blood of god all right guys well have a
great weekend and guess what
yeah h3
forever sunday everybody's getting a new
episode of leftovers we ain't done with
the week yet
and members can watch it on saturday
thank you to all of our members thank
you everybody members and thank you to
everyone who's just watching we love all
of you love
bts
oh we're planning a squid games episode
next week though that's going to be
really fun if you guys like science
library exciting unless i gotta watch it
if anyone hasn't watched it go and watch
it over the weekend yeah he was doing
something else this week though maybe
i've i've got a power through attack on
titan or a b is just gonna it's gonna
there's a lot of episodes well i just
finished the third season so we're like
i'm almost caught up i ask them every
day the new season has a lot it says
like 22 episodes doesn't it
well not the new one i got some homework
to do that wait but you haven't watched
school you're gonna you're we're gonna
use good game you guys are gonna watch
this i guess maybe i appreciate it sorry
abe but man's been missing out on this
cultural phenomenon because of squid
game i have one episode left square
well attack on titan ain't going
anywhere
doing it next week you got to know what
the [ __ ] we're doing okay okay
somebody's asking can the show end with
the classic h3 podcast music
oh yeah play it wait peace there's
something else i wanted to say oh uh you
can play the music now as we're signing
out but
should we do one more poll on the
thumbnail for
um
[Music]
yeah you want to do it silence
so what where's our thumbnail at camera
he checked the views on that thing he's
on it
oh phase banks dm'd me oh
don't read it out loud
i guess he saw
or maybe not
okay
um
i want to read it it's not bad
it's a private message is it okay okay i
mean if you're trying to squash it with
him that like immediately
reading out his dm is probably not a
good way to do that so that's true
i mean it's all for the show
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh i'm sure it's not him yeah
no don't worry it seems like he wants to
talk
right okay
interesting yeah interesting
so you guys like this is it is it this
good or good representation do you think
of the silent library
uh
yeah i like it i think people will like
to be able to find what they're looking
for right right
is there too much writing with the
silent library and then the h3 podcast
here or you'd think it's fine
that doesn't move me
all right let me check the views on that
because it's gonna drop
that's what i hate is that
it's gonna tank after you change it
let me just read some super chats while
you're doing that
uh because there's been quite a few go
ahead samantha said i think everyone
who's worked at a grocery store has a
poop story unfortunately i think yeah
right uh
another samantha different samantha said
ladies please stop throwing away your
tampons into the toilet with peace and
love
um
oh i'm sorry somebody donated twenty
dollars i'm sorry i can't uh pronounce
your name but it said ethan you scared
my mom so bad with those thumbnails she
wouldn't stop asking what's wrong
[Applause]
let's see i'm looking
i know there's a lot and i'm sorry i
won't be able to read them all so i'm
just looking for like the the big boys
uh there's somebody getting married
tomorrow tomorrow and going to where
teddy first to the wedding i don't know
how
to the wedding
i wonder which i wonder what's the
outfit my boss katelyn
all right
uh eric contreras donated 20 bucks said
my fiance works in a middle school and
someone's devious lick was stealing a
soap dispenser filling it with piss and
then putting it back yeah
oh that's [ __ ] that
is
degeneracy personified
that's a crime bro what the hell yeah uh
but do you know what i 100 believe it
yeah definitely in middle school that's
what goes down man
uh
let's see let's see if there's any other
juicy i was just doing this to fill it
while you were
i'm
listening oh okay
uh there was a lot of donations of
people saying that they got instagram
when they were 10 11 which god that
makes me feel old because i was in
college when it came out
but that it helped trigger their eating
and multiple people saying it made them
feel fat triggered eating disorder so
yeah
not the best thing i was probably around
that age right yeah
crazy um
that's wild i don't know how do you like
how does it affect you growing up with
instagram
i mean i don't know any different i
guess right yeah we were like the last
generation to grow up without that level
like like we were saying we had aim and
stuff but it was just such a different
experience
we got a smartphone when we were in our
20s already right yeah the first time i
ever saw a smartphone i was almost done
with college right yeah and my rich
friend had it and i had never seen
anyone else with it before
i think we need to bring back tower
records the first time for me seeing a
smartphone
somebody said everybody should sit at
the table uh some everybody should
be at the table of their worst silent
library moment i guess they're saying
what the worst moment for them was i
mean my worst moment was watching ian
eat that [ __ ] fish
without a doubt and it didn't even
happen to me just watching
the fish by far
by far
uh
20 ethan did seem pretty lonely when ela
and theodore went to israel late night
denny's sounds reasonable to me oh my
gosh i ordered food i wouldn't leave my
in all of my life that i know ethan yeah
he would never go by himself to a
dentist
anywhere or anywhere
no no no no
i refueled all charges
these accusations just keep stacking up
dude i don't know what to tell you i
would go on
my back got my back on this [ __ ] i would
go on uh what do you call it
lie detector
you go on record i will go and when you
when you can't lie like when it's
perjury oh you you you would you would
testify on their own
testify under oh there's no way
that you can do that
i know ela is busy
and much more now so with the pregnancy
but if the uh is there any potential is
getting a behind the scenes for what the
process of designing and producing a
teddy fresh product is that's
interesting
um
i guess i should think about how to make
one like that but that would be cool
yeah just like a little mini dock
release on the website or something just
it's been so busy it's been crazy yeah
um
but
yeah it's uh it could be interesting i
agree
somebody donated 50 bucks and said name
him jared leto klein i don't think that
they're going to do that
i'm going to go out online
i do want to say a lot of people pointed
out that his initials will be bk
burger king
oh i was like what's the problem yeah
okay because he was he was talking a lot
of [ __ ] on burger king the other day so
people are asking in the chat
about me never puking why is this
bro oh we were talking because we always
talked about it well because we were
doing all these gross out things on the
library
yeah i don't know what's the deal
i never either that's insane just never
just flat out
never and um i've been like blackout
drunk
right
where like i didn't remember how i got
home
but i still didn't puke that's insane
that's insane that's pretty amazing you
should i'm jealous it's weird it's a
human it's part of being a human i mean
i feel like you got it
if i brush and i like put the toothbrush
in too much or something then i do get
that you get the dry hair yeah i do get
that so i'm like so what
i don't know
very weird
[Music]
uh it's my 24th birthday today can i get
a hell yeah from the whole crew
hell yeah brother
[Applause]
i'll give you a dream style hell yeah
yeah hell yeah hell yeah yeah
good i just messaged uh phase
blanks
maybe you should stop calling facebook
yeah
should i say that what we're working on
in november
that i don't have any details yet on no
okay
what you're talking about well the drums
have already started we're working on or
the what for what it's for the event you
can talk about the event
okay um we're planning a pop-up for 30
fresh in november
l.a
l.a party people
i'm excited gonna be fun um i don't have
any details yet because we're just
putting it all together now but we'll be
there it's going to be a fan meetup
slash teddy fresh pop-up
and um
it's going to be fun
fun activities
there's going to be
other stuff
as well
yeah i just i don't know how much to say
yet so i'll wait
oh wait but yeah it's a big project for
us
concert don't shoot me
no i was just threatening i would never
dare you
no well we were thinking about that that
was on the table musicians were famous
to come to it but it was just going to
get too big just feel like it's our
first event so we should take it slow
that's good so maybe the next one i just
don't want to like drop the ball we
could do like a teddy fresh
teddy festival
first of all and then you can bring like
all of our musician friends just for the
name alone
teddy festival is pretty cool that's a i
mean just that's too good of a name to
not use you kind of have to now
because we could get some good acts
there i think
obviously it would cost a lot of money
but it would be worth it yeah
that'd be cool mega just threw 20 bucks
uh teenage mutant ninja turtle tf collab
when i think we actually had the
opportunity to license that and we
passed didn't we
oh god i can't remember
it would have been sick for splinter to
be the bear
i don't know that we had the pretending
i remember thinking we yeah no we we can
do teenage we're in touch with i think
we can i think we definitely can do a
teenage mutant ninja turtle because i
know
the ip person we work with is in touch
with them
danger ninja turtle was my [ __ ] jam
when i was a little bit mine i loved it
loved
it let's talk about it because i don't
know why
let's
let's revisit that i was a ninja turtle
for like
five halloweens in a row when i was
really
i'm not having a badass
i love it all yeah who's your favorite
turtle you know when i was a kid my
favorite was always leonardo because he
was the leader
but looking back
was he the producer
the red ones i was about to say no
leonardo's the blue one
raphael kind of the [ __ ] yeah i mean i
kind of like because he's the more like
anti-hero one he's the vegeta of uh
he's just a more interesting character
because he's more like conflicted and
he's angry and stupid
because he's the hater exactly
yeah when i was a kid it was always leo
but like looking at it he's kind of
vanilla he's the more complex
he's the more complex interesting
character fascinating yes exactly
exactly well
hard-hitting uh questions here today
well listen been a great app
had a lot of fun and i'm just so excited
to uh put out our second episode of the
leftovers on sunday yeah so that's
great and um
oh how we see faze banks when cordially
dming
what is this when he had your stuff here
what is this
what's the joke
i believe that is the joke that cam
can you clarify damn you want to come
cam you want to come clarify we're
trying to make ladies here
cameron cameron that's weirdly quiet
over there
is it just a hair joke or what
yeah it's just literally just a
hairdresser it's a hairdresser yeah i
just dropped the original image in there
legend when cordially dming this legend
grows all of his hair yeah he's a thick
hair
head of hair yeah he's got a great head
hair yeah you know
let me see that hairline though pull
that back
that's a photograph yeah and here's
speaking of beautiful legends
so we really like this one huh okay
we'll say goodbye to all the views we're
getting
last superchat emma said frontline
worker here everyone keep wearing your
mask oh are you going to read it yeah no
go ahead everyone keep wearing your mask
peace and love peace and love you got it
you will that's why it's for you
[Music]
this was the
bank's photo
that cam edited so
harry legend
he said arie legend alright guys
they need a
bath today
[Music]
it's been a while since i played this
well yeah i mean we've updated it over
the years but yeah this is the oh geez
[Applause]
[Music]
um
all right guys see you on sunday oh and
everyone go watch the silent library if
you haven't okay
help us out
please
and if it doesn't say silent library
it's a picture of me it's a picture of
me in the hospital
look for the video of me in the hospital
all right thank you
[Music]
you